hello everyone welcome to
chainsenses.com so we are here live
again from panama we are gonna have a
look today at everything that happened
on the market yesterday so we're gonna
of course go to what is hot so we had
some strong moves happening on moonland
on bbig so we're gonna have a look at
that we're of course gonna go through
the price action of amc and gme because
i know that this is what you want to see
every day
we also gonna have a look at the oil
market which is uh the focus right now
about the equity market everybody is
watching the next move of uh eu are they
gonna ban oil from russia or not so this
is what the market is focusing on at the
moment so we're gonna have a look at the
uh price we're also gonna have a look at
um silver gold x which is squeezing and
we have some strong moves happening on
bitcoin
so
morning everyone bonjour money
hey bro
okay let me just come back guys and make
a coffee quickly
so we're going to start i think with
mulan and bbig
because those two stocks are right now
very hot
we can see the volume happening we have
some um some things happening as well on
the option market so we're gonna have a
look at that i fixed my spreadsheet
yesterday it was not working uh today is
good so we're gonna have a look at the
synthetic short we're gonna have a look
at um
at the dtc at everything that can help
us to know if a squeeze is likely to
happen and we're gonna discuss also
squeeze targets and see what is the
stock that is the more likely to squeeze
and i have an answer for that so
let's start very soon
and of course guys
let me know what you want to see i'm
going to keep an eye on the chat
so
so here we go let's start like i said
let's first have a look at all right bb
aging
so yesterday i made some analysis about
bbig
and i was telling you that we have this
trendline all right that gave us already
so this trendline is created i'm using a
logarithmic scale remember that whenever
we are analyzing stocks that are moving
a lot it is better to use the log scale
because it gives
um it makes the curve less flat and it's
easier to draw trend lines uh using the
logarithmic scale so for those who are
using trading view just right click here
and you can move from regular scale
which as you can see is not giving much
information i mean it's giving
information but not as clear as the log
scale so using the logarithmic scale
what we have here
uh we can see that we had a breakout
with volume but without consolidation
once again it's very important to have
this consolidation before a breakout and
then it um it didn't work we had a fake
out we came back at it we got rejected
all right and for the past week we have
again
a situation that is to me similar to
what was happening back in jan so let me
remind you what was the reason about
this move up if i remember well it was
about the cryptid spin-off that bb-8g is
going to have
in early 2022 so it can happen anytime
so i think this news is coming back
again
and we can see
that we have those strong moves up
happening on increasing volume all right
and we can compare first thing
what was uh the
volume trading
before right so the volume trading here
you see it was much bigger so this
information tells us that we have still
some energy
to um
that buyers have more energy to keep
buying shares because the volume can be
bigger so this is one information then
we have again this breakout yesterday
for the first time we closed above this
trend line again okay so this is the
level i was monitoring
and i would not personally buy here if i
use my methods because my methods rely
on the fact that we need to have a
consolidation before the breakout which
is creating a nice support below which
you can put a stop loss so here we are
not in this case so it's it's it's more
a gamble um but it's looking hard and it
might very well go at least to 4 20. but
once again
this situation is not perfect to me to
set up a trade here
let's quickly go at uh let's have a look
at what we have on the uh
synthetic shot yes because the synthetic
short
is giving us some information
so bam bam bam
bbig
okay so here guys as you know i'm
retrieving the information about uh the
option market
okay
and bbsg is hot guys because we have uh
a lot of options so i'm receiving right
now the put options
so that i have the full vision about the
option market on bb agent okay so let's
analyze this information together
let me make sure everything is good okay
so here what we can see
is that uh
first
the regular short as of february 28th
which is the last available date is 17
so it might not seem very big but we
have a lot of options we have
uh 21
of synthetic short that is coming from
call options so let's see where they
come from
i'm checking at the biggest
positions
so march 18th has expired i'm not taking
this into account
so it's april okay april here april 5
call okay this is the most both one
and this is of course um
something that can create troubles for
market maker so here what i wanted to
show you is that we have 21 of synthetic
short 17 of regular short so it's a
total short of 40 percent but the volume
trading is very big so in terms of dtc
we have only one point uh 1.8 guys so
let's check last time it squeezed how
many
what was the synthetic shot
okay because we can compare
oh right so i have this information here
okay it was very long time ago i didn't
record it but it was roughly around the
same level so we are in the same
situation as we were
when we had uh this strong move up so
let's see guys here it's a gamble i can
give you the resistance levels that are
the first resistance level is at 420
so this is a level where we might see a
rejection happening but usually after
breakout this breakout is better than
this one the reason why is that here
the price action had more time as you
can see to consolidate around this area
so it's a long term consideration if i
look at the weekly time frame
we can see it better
okay
so you can see the price action posed
here and it was testing this trend line
multiple times so now this breakout is
to me much better quality so um
here i would give a bullish
um
to me here we are of course bullish i
think we're going to go to 420 then
what's gonna happen there is to me a 50
50 situation all right guys so let me
quickly have a look at your question hey
bro
morning
okay amc look bullish
okay we're gonna have a look at amc when
most andrew so most could happen to me
in april or may rather may and i showed
you that before already i can show you
quickly again
um
and so this is amc charts
okay
the reason why
something might happen in may
is because we have here this gigantic
triangle that is ending as you can see
around may june it depends where the
press action is the higher the press
action the earlier the triangle ends
okay so here for example if we come back
to the 18 level on the 17th of may we're
gonna uh arrive at the end of the
strangle so the market would need to
choose a direction and if things are
going better in the economy if the
correction that we see on the global
market is behind us uh it would probably
be on the upside but we don't know
what's going to happen on the market so
we need to be prepared for every
scenario but in may 17th on may 17th
something will probably
i mean something big will probably
happen on amc
all right guys so
i'm gonna redo amc technical analysis
later
but i wanted to show you um
yeah i wanted to show you so i did bbig
once again let me sum up here the
situation we have a breakout that is
better quality than before this is a
little bit the same situation that we
had uh in jan 22. uh the synthetic shot
and regular shots are high the volume
trading is not at
as big as it could be so we can we have
here some room for buyers to buy more
shares so this is a bullish information
so
let's see what's going to happen but my
take is that i think we're going to move
higher and i don't see the price action
going below 280 at the moment where we
have some support created by this trend
line and 420 is the first resistance and
if we break that
then i mean we really need to know
what's going to happen about uh the
cryptid spinoff because um
when this news is going to happen i
don't know if we're going to buy the
rumor sell the new situation or
if it's going to be even more exciting
for investors because things are going
to happen there and for every 10 shares
in bbig they have one share in the uh
cryptid spin-off so
this might as well create some more
bullish momentum in bbig so we okay
market is opening so we open the render
flatish right now
okay
let me have a look guys at um milan
so i'm done with bbig i'm doing milan
that is correcting a little bit like i
said yesterday i did uh mulan guys and i
told you that
360 was a resistance level we went there
but we were not able to close above we
got rejected and we closed below so
right now
let's first quickly have a look at the
technicals so as you know volume is
important macd is important volatility
is important so
here we definitely have a breakout that
happened above 180 since then we're
moving higher but we have not
consolidated so
a small period of consideration could
make sense here we can see the volume
trading is still high
even on the red day so it's better on
the red day it's better to see the
volume going lower which means that
whenever bears are winning a battle uh
there is not a lot of buyers that lost
money okay so it's important for strong
move up to develop to have those
consolidation those uh corrections but
happening on lower volume so here the
volume is quite high guys so
um
so i'm not sure uh that boos are able to
you know just push higher without uh
giving some ground to the bears so let's
see
and what is interesting in milan so i
want to go through that with you today
is to have a look at what is happening
on
the option market
okay so i'm doing the same thing i'm
using my spreadsheet i'm retrieving all
the options it's very important to keep
an eye on those options because
this is um
this is give you giving you a lot of
information about the momentum all right
bama
okay
so here i'm retrieving the put options
okay
so
the first information that we can see
is that the regular shot is not that big
is only 1.2 percent and i remember it
was much bigger than that a few weeks
ago
so we need to uh wonder what happened
here and i think that you guys are
probably aware of that
but maybe some of you are not and
uh to know to understand why the short
interest has dropped
from around forty percent to it was even
more than that i think
to only one point two percent
we need to check what is the outstanding
number of shares and the outstanding
number of shares i get it here okay so i
already had munan
here
and for every day since uh the 28th of
feb till the 15th of march i'm
retrieving the outstanding number of
shares and as you can see on the 28th of
february
we had 35 million shares on them on the
market and on the 1st of march we had
188 million shares available on the
market so the equity float went from 25
million to 178 million alright so we
basically get got some our shares
uh dilution so bam
okay
cells were diluted by seven so for this
reason if the if the regular shot
interest in in terms of number of shares
is equal we're going to have a synthetic
in a regular shot in terms of percentage
that is divided by seven and this is why
the regular shot is so small right now
but it can of course uh rebuild and i
want to have a look at what happened on
that day because it's interesting once
again to
understand
what is happening on this market and
here as you can see
on the 28th of february so we saw that
here there were a share emission they
emitted 150 million shares so from
on the 28th of feb and on this day uh
milan took 145 percent so we understand
the price was much higher and they
probably needed some liquidity so they
emitted shares for this reason we got a
dump the next day but investors were
strong enough they bought everything all
right we had 150 million more shares on
the market but it got bought and
we went
much higher every day since then so
right now
in terms of synthetics in terms of short
interest i don't see
any big risk for shorts all right let's
be honest so for this reason i think
that bbig as you saw bbig had a total
short interest of around 60 so it's a
lot mulan has now with this new number
of shares only six percent so we are not
talking at all about the same uh numbers
here and the dtc is of course very small
because the volume trading is high we
have 0.05
so to me
uh i don't see a squeeze happening
happening on milan but the market cap is
not very big only 600 million us dollars
so we can we could very well see the
press action uh continuing ripping uh on
the to continue reaping
and reaching some nice levels but this
would wouldn't be i think
um a short squeeze
so let's see what's gonna happen here
okay give me some likes guys once again
let me show you where i am i am at
gabrielle's place so gabriel is with me
on this call we're gonna do some trading
today again uh we are in panama guys
it's amazing i just arrived here
uh two days ago and i'm gonna do some uh
some live trading with you very soon
we're gonna see if uh i'm gonna do some
day trading on the mcnjme or if i'm
gonna go on uh the spy or maybe some
forex we're gonna see what you guys
prefer
but it's going to be very exciting i'm
very excited about this
so let's have a look at the other stocks
that we have and everything that was hot
so like i said right now the focus is on
the commodity market let's discuss a bit
what is happening on the global market
so
um
let's have a look maybe
at okay
let's have a look at the
spy it was pre-market flatish okay so
this is interesting
we are moving up 60 beeps but once again
remember yesterday we were checking this
445 level uh that was resistance we got
a rejection uh from this py on the
200-day moving average
when i was live with you we got rejected
and then we came back so this is a small
correction a small consolidation but as
you can see it happened on lower volume
okay which is good and right now we are
opening just below and we are about to
break it so this is looking quite good
to me
and like i said i think that we have
some room on the upside on the spy and
that we might
very well
come back to the 400
at least 450 level which is the next
resistance
the next resistance is actually here
okay 447 let me place it here
okay so i think that on the global
market we can very well continue to push
higher we took back some energy here
yesterday with the small consolidation
uh
everything is rather bullish we don't
have much news happening coming in the
coming week we only have once again this
focus on the energy prices which is
creating inflation so everybody i mean
investors are looking at that
so
here like i said rather bullish
maybe we're gonna come come to 460 which
is resistance oscillate a little bit
here and then we need to see what's
going to happen and what is very
important
like i said yesterday uh when you check
the global market is to have a look at
the vix
okay guys so bam
okay so vixx is dropping so this is
totally in line with what we see but
it's still above 20. so as long as we
don't have a vx that is coming below 20
which is showing that the can is
restored in the market that the
volatility is dropping um we might very
well see some uh some strong moves down
happening from time to time so we can
very well have more volatility because
as you guys are aware of we still are in
a situation that is not fully under
control regarding the war
regarding the inflation so this is
uh what we need to pay attention to this
volatility that is going to tell us if
investors are finally uh you know calm
and not afraid of what could happen
so let's have a look right now guys at
amc and gme because i can see it's
moving then i'm gonna have a look at the
oil market guys because like i said the
focus is is here
for now
all right so amc what did we have
yesterday bam bam bam
so i'm on the daily time frame i'm using
here a regular scale because it's giving
me better information
once again you need to switch from one
to the other to see what trend lines are
giving you the best reactions to know
what traders are using and on amc i can
see that right now traders are using the
regular scale right before it was log
so it's just switching
so here what do we have we were like i
said coming below the 14.5 level but
booze managed to take back control and
right now we are you know moving higher
but we still have this decreasing volume
so the analysis i did yesterday is still
holding for now um
both are back in control in the short
term but there is nothing uh there is no
clear signal of uh boost taking back
control on the medium term which could
help us to go back you know to this
resistance area that is around
around 20
23
depending when we go there once again
this is created by this
big triangle that i have here
okay so if we are able to come back to
this area so around 25
uh then we would have a big battle
between buus and bears because there are
a lot of bears sitting here and once
again the best scenario is that we
arrive there we consolidate okay so the
earlier we arrived there the better it
is we have this kind of consolidation
and then we have a breakout this would
be a very very good information about
what could uh about a strong move that
could happen okay so we are looking for
this kind of pattern let me quickly have
a look at uh so once again to sum up the
situation on
amc just regarding the technicals we
still have low volume so no clear signal
from there uh the volatility is low so a
strong move could happen any time
because whenever the volatility starts
to be very low usually then we uh it's
easier for one camp to take control so
for example for booze by buying a lot of
shares and to push the price action at
much higher levels when whenever a lot
of shares are trading it requires more
energy to do the same kind of moves so a
low volatility with low volume period is
better for reversal to happen and right
now we are a bit in this situation so
let's see what can happen
okay
and yeah i wanted quickly to show you
what we have in terms of
synthetic short on amc
it's not going to take much longer but
it's good to keep an eye on that to see
if the the open interest is rebuilding
or not
okay so
this one has expired
okay so you see for now guys we are
still at quite low levels in terms of
maximum synthetic short which is telling
us
what is the total open interest on call
options and for now it is not very big
because we had some big expiry that
occurred like march 18th and for now
investors have not rolled their position
uh into those very high strikes which is
showing that for now investors are in a
wait and see mode and uh we're gonna see
if this open interest is rebuilt or not
so what else do we have as you can see
guys gabriel is coming back so we're
gonna of course discuss with him what is
happening on the commodity market
because he's a commodity trader
yesterday was a very good day for him
today we're gonna see
so bam bam bam
what else do we have
yeah we can have a look at the max spain
it's al
always a good information
so the maximum pain i remind you guys
what it is it is the level that creates
the more pain for investors all right
for option holders so it is the level
that is the best for option market
makers and when they do their trades
they always try to push the price at the
price action there so of course they
cannot do it uh each time
but they are trying
okay
so
okay so this one is for april
april 14th guys
okay so as you can see let me change
this quickly
okay
so it's quite high guys as you can see
here we have the p l
of the total options that we have on
april 14th okay this curve and we are
looking for the lowest level and the
lowest level
is around 18
okay
18 even maybe 20. okay you can see it's
rather flattish here
so
we don't have you know it's pretty much
the same for market makers but
definitely it's between 17 and 20. okay
so let's see if market makers are able
to push the price towards this level
on april 14th so it's pretty good
uh what else do we have the total shot
is 20 the tc
dtc is 2.5 okay so let me compare that
with what we had before because once
again what is important is to see the
dynamics of this option market okay so
we need to compare that to what we had
before and as you can see
um
the last time i did that was on march
12
and we were having a dtc of 2.2 so now
it is growing a little bit all right
guys because the price is higher we the
price was at 14.3 so the higher we go
the more in the money are the call
options and the bigger is the synthetic
short so the bigger is the dtc so here
as you can see i think the low is behind
us okay
we can see clearly a dynamic on the dtc
okay
look at that
okay
so this is the dtc
one month all right
so here
we were at 3.5 when amc was about to
squeeze in november 21 all right so
four months four five months ago then we
dropped because amc dropped then we
bottomed with the dtc at two and right
now guys this is interesting because
look amc is moving sideways but the dtc
is moving higher all right so this is a
good
signal okay it is not of course enough
to say that boos are back in control on
the long term or medium term because for
now bears and control
but
it is a very good signal of a potential
reversal and even maybe squeeze that's
going to happen within one or two months
once again let me repeat guys why this
could happen in one or two months
okay so what is happening now yeah
we open higher we're moving a little bit
lower okay but like i said
whatever happens in the coming one or
two months it's not very important it's
better of course we go first higher than
consolidate but if we consolidate first
and then go higher i mean the outcome
would be to me the same what is very
important is what is what is going to
happen in april or may when we're gonna
be here and if you guys were watching my
video back in the time i was saying
exactly the same thing in november but
of course i was bullish guys and i was
hoping for an upside breakout we had a
downside breakout okay so those
triangles whenever they have a breakout
they are usually followed by a strong
move in the same direction if the
breakout occurs on increasing volume and
this is um
you know this is how
this is how i personally build my view
i'm looking for breakouts i'm looking if
the volume is here and if i have good
breakout with volume and consideration
then it tells me that the market will
probably keep pushing in this direction
oh right so what else do we see
okay
so rsi is still below 50 guys so we need
to um to wait a bit to see if both i'm
again able to go above 50 as you can see
each time it arrived close to the 50
area
like here it got rejected okay so as you
can see this is another indicator that
you can follow if we're able to stay
above 50
for more more than a week then it means
that something
more is happening on this market that
bulls are really able to you know keep
the price action at higher levels and
and better not able to push it lower all
right so this is what we want to see we
want to see bulls keeping the price
action high for at least a week
so that uh it means that the the bullish
sentiment is back okay guys
so
let me have a look at gme
then once again we're gonna have a look
at what is happening on the oil market
guys on the commodities as well we're to
quickly have a look at silver and gold
that is not doing amazingly today
so
first
i'm actually adding up
you adding because yesterday i reduced a
bit because it was uh
i was i'm in there for a while okay so
yesterday i really used to be to pack
profit okay and yesterday like today i
see it's really
kind of going against so i'm adding uh
i'm adding okay so so basically i don't
know if you guys remember yesterday we
were discussing about a spread between
gold and silver and this is a position
that gabriel uh is having for a couple
of weeks and um today the spread is
widening okay so silver is dropping more
than gold so he is adding to this
position and i think that uh like we saw
yesterday this is a trade that in the
long term is often uh working this
spread is finally gonna come back so
this is a strategy that uh is good to
use
but you need to be able to
kind of
you know it can go against you like
maybe a week or two so you need to be
able to to take this pressure
you shouldn't size it oversize it i
would say okay
so you see the tips guys is like don't
oversize always you know this this is
nothing very new but keep this in mind
if you have a position that you can
handle and that you can add more you can
keep uh you can keep your position even
when you are having a loss so this is
very important to be able to hold your
position until you finish in the morning
all right
so i'm keeping gold and silver for later
what else we have bitcoin guys i wanted
to go with you through what is happening
on bitcoin then i'm gonna quickly have a
look
also max pen bbig good to show okay
we're gonna have uh okay let me quickly
have a look at that right now
okay
okay so i'm retrieving the call options
now i'm retrieving the put options guys
as usual shift f9 shift f9
okay
no not yet it's coming
okay
here we go
do you have everything okay let me check
uh
ah okay no i didn't get it sorry my bad
i was not using the good strikes i
didn't refresh okay
[Music]
so i'm here
computing the maximum pain of dbig by
retrieving all the options
that we have on the option market
okay put options are coming
so as you can see we have a lot of good
options as well guys on bbig but the
number of collapsion is far far bigger
which makes a big synthetic shot of 22
okay
so
here we go
it's an interesting curve
that we have okay so here is the
piano options that we have on april 14th
for bbig
so as you can see it's hard to really
have good information from that because
i can give you the max pane okay it is
two points
it is
around three
but the curve is very flat
okay between two point three
and let's say three point one is very
flat so we have a maximum pain that is
below the level we are seeing now but
once again this maximum pain
is
you know just something that is
attracting the price
but it is not the most important
indicator to have a look at the most
important thing guys once again i'm
coming back quickly to bbig
the most important thing is the volume
guys okay
volume breakouts this is what you need
to keep in mind if you want to know who
is in control if you see a breakout on
increasing volume this is usually
followed by a strong move in the same
direction and another interesting
information about the volume is that you
can check what was the maximum volume
traded last time this kind of event
happened and we can have a look at that
because bbig is i mean doing this kind
of moves for
almost one year and as you can see
so the biggest volume traded was in
september 21 we arrive at 320 million
shares okay
then
the next time it happened was in jan 22
once again with
it was about the news of the
cryptid spin-off
jan 20 jan 18 the volume traded was 280
million shares and for now guys we are
only trading 86 million shares so we
still have some room for buyers to buy
more shares like they did before and we
are at the pro at the price that is
lower than it was when we
you know kind of squeezed i don't know
if you can call it a squeeze because the
shorts didn't really cover here because
we we can see we still have a lot of
short on this market so it's not a
squeeze guys if it squeeze
if we have a real squeeze okay let's
discuss a little bit squeeze targets on
bbig because bbig each time tried to go
higher but as you can see shorts have
never covered all right shorts
still keep the position they still
believe that bbig
can go lower okay this is debut
but
if things
really you know go
wide and we see some massive moves so
first when would this happen this would
happen i think around the 420 level okay
if
we are able to go above 420
like we did here but if we stay there
more than a day okay we stayed here one
day and the next day we got rejected
okay so this 420 level is very important
and once again we have the 200-day
moving average at
415. so this level is a level that asset
managers and big money players are
always keeping an eye on okay i remind
you guys the quick rule you can use if
we are below that it means that on the
long term uh bears and control if we are
above that it means bulls and control
and each of those camps will use this
200-day moving average to increase their
position
okay so if we are able to go above that
level what could happen
is we can have a look at the option
market guys because it's giving very
good information
okay the reason being that whenever a
big strike is crossed
it creates as you know a lot of troubles
for market makers that need to buy
during um when the price action is
actually crossing the strike and here we
can see that the biggest strike on the
upside is 10 okay
is it on apple
it's probably on april
bam bam bam so i produce here now
six
okay ten okay it's an apple guys so if
something is to happen first thing is
going to be before april 14th okay first
information
because after that it's going to be much
easier for schultz to control what is
happening all right this is the reason
behind that
and we could see
a move
i mean close to 12
14. i don't see the price action going
higher than that to be honest if we are
able to reach those levels
i mean if you are in this trade not
financial advice but taking profits
would be a very very nice
trade already and bam bam bam what else
do we have
i'm checking if we don't have a gap here
you know because those gap fillers as
well
can have an impact on the price action
we have a lot of traders that are
trading gaps on
short maturities and they usually
involve big sizes
okay we have a small gap
here that has never been filled okay so
this is one more thing that you can pay
uh attention to
so once again the squeeze targets guys
would be between
let's say
nine and 12 okay something like that
like that this would be i think the best
uh case scenario for bbig if you arrive
there it's probably gonna get dumped
okay this is only my view
okay let's have a look guys at gme jimmy
is coming back guys okay
so
like i said yesterday i did gme
yesterday i bought back some calls that
i had because i was having a covered
call strategy with me that which means
that i have shares and that i'm selling
a call uh to cash in some premium
yesterday i bought back the school uh
because we were having and i did that
live with you guys we were having this
massive volume and you remember how you
should interpret the volume whenever we
have low volume on during a low
volatility period so a consolidation on
low volume then whenever you see a
strong volume happening with a big move
usually there is momentum that is
created after that and a lot of buyers
hear about this a strong move and are
jumping in the trade so this is what is
happening on jamie today and we can see
jme is moving up by six percent
okay so like i said yesterday the first
resistance on gme is at
115 created
uh sorry 104 so we are coming close to
it created by the 20 day moving average
guys okay
so this is
something
that we can keep an eye on but it's not
a very strong resistance okay the very
strong resistance you can try to find it
yourself look at this chart
okay i will remove quickly the drawings
just okay look at that the information
is here in front of your eyes
what is creating the resistance here
okay
you can see it's pretty obvious it's not
the 20-day moving average so the 20 days
of course acting as support and
resistance as it always does as you can
see a little bit here here as well one
reaction that was uh that rejected the
price action
and here
what is very important to keep an eye on
guys is that this 50-day moving average
which is right now at
109.00 now
that is what right now 109 is creating
the uh
the resistance area okay guys
so my take is that let me get back to
drawings
okay
okay so i don't think the 20-day moving
average will be strong enough to
stop the price actually moving higher
but i think we might see some
consideration some maybe uh small
correction happening around the 109th
level so let's see
maybe around here you see
so i would personally not do anything
for now on my position i'm happy with it
okay
and let's see what is important guys on
gme let's have a look at the important
levels okay so once again
bam i'm switching to regular scale as
you can see i'm always switching from
log scale to regular scale and you
should do the same okay you just compare
the two of them you draw some lines and
you see where you have the best
reactions okay
and here same as for amc guys but those
stocks are as you know moving together
so now like i said yesterday guys we can
see that if jamie is moving strongly up
for now amc is today only uh up four
percent and yeah i don't know if you
remember but we checked yesterday um who
was leading the move and gme had two or
three percent uh
was moving up two or three percent
before amc so today mc has four percent
delay i would say in this move up so it
should catch up at some point so let's
see but for now jme guys um
yeah so you can see this triangle here
is ending same thing guys is ending
around
you know april may so let's see what's
going to happen my take is that we're
going to move sideways guys okay maybe a
little up a little down little bit up a
little bit down consolidate here and
we're gonna have this big question that
is gonna be asked
are we gonna move higher or lower of
course we hope for a move higher but
it's gonna once again depends on what is
happening on the global market because
as you know to have a proper squeeze we
need to have the bullish sentiment back
on the global market but for now what
i'm seeing is very good we can see spy
up 80 bibs guys
right now
so once again this 200-day moving
average is very important to close above
on the daily time frame so it's looking
good for now
but it is not enough to conclude that um
that we're gonna go to 460 or 470 we
still need to see if we are able to
close above that level or not okay
so i'm checking quickly what is
happening on the hourly timeframe you
can see guys on the spy and that's why i
want to do some live trading with you
day trading on sp y because when you use
the hourly timeframe on the spy i mean
technical analysis is um
is very clean and here for example it's
pretty obvious that the 20 hour moving
average is you know acting as support
for the price action so if you want to
trade this move up you know you just buy
whenever you were coming close to here
you put a stop loss just below and and
you ride the the move up all right
that's uh that's how it works so i want
to do that with you guys i want to show
you how it works because this is what
i've been doing when i was working as a
professional trader i was using the
hourly time frame sometimes 15 minutes
time frame and taking positions you know
either i was buying the dip oh i was
buying breakouts so we're gonna do uh
both of those strategies and we're gonna
see which one is working the best
okay
so let me quickly have a look at your
questions don't hesitate guys if you
want me to do anything here i'm seeing
blackberry it's been a long time i
didn't do blackberry
so we can have a look at that
case keeper patrick
okay the 360 resistance so skipper has a
good question because on my discord we
will of course discussing bbig
um you know
last
month and in jan whenever we had this
squeeze happening and 360 was at that
time the resistance level
so as you can see 360 is here so skipper
is asking a very good question is 360
still resistance so i would say
that it is resistance
but uh
the major resistance is higher because
we have a double resistance created at 4
20. why double because we have this here
consolidation
here as well we have a lot of recent
highs and we have the
200-day moving average so we can call it
the we can call the area 360 420 the
resistance area okay
all right guys so uh i want to go
through my watch list as well with you
today this is what i'm using to take my
position so i think it's interesting
that you see that as well
i want to discuss as well what is
happening on bitcoin we're going to go
to bitcoin very soon guys
okay
okay i saw you bro
i'm gonna have a look at that i'm gonna
have a look at blackberry i'm gonna have
a look at bbby
but first
uh let's have a look at the at today's
opportunity so once again for those who
were not here yesterday let me remind
you quickly what is the spreadsheet in
this spreadsheet i'm basically keeping a
track of
around 200 stocks right
as you can see here if i don't put my
alerts
have around 200 stocks and for each of
them i'm monitoring some levels okay so
it's like swing trading so i'm talking
here about levels uh that i'm getting
using some technical analysis for the
medium term like a few months that
that's why it's quite easy actually to
handle you don't have to change those
levels very often
and i'm keeping an eye on um either
some opportunities to buy the deep so
i'm going to put some support levels or
some resistance levels and whenever the
price action is coming close to this
resistance levels i'm gonna have a look
at um at the breakout situation so i'm
gonna be looking for low volume
consolidation and ideally then a
breakout on increasing volume and if i
have that then i like to take a position
so here my alerts are basically just
formula as you can see you know
so i'm using this formula of course um
it's not that complicated but uh you
need to
understand a little bit how excel is
working if you want to do that
and then i'm just gonna keep the ones
that are giving me an alert an alert is
created whenever we are around two
standard deviation uh from the levels i
want to see so here today
those are the alerts i'm getting so a
lot of them were already here yesterday
but i wanna have a look at the new ones
so d e guys
we saw this one yesterday but this one
is hot i didn't post an alert and i'm
gonna explain to you why on my discord
uh bam bam bam
okay
so ge look at that guys weekly time
frame
okay so this is a very nice breakout but
tell me what is the issue here okay have
a look at that
and
for those who followed my course or for
those who are watching my video
regularly
you are able to tell me what is missing
here okay so the breakout is here
okay because we have this consolidation
period
uh
so first you need to check if we have
low volatility
and
during the consideration and then a
breakout okay so to check if we have a
low volatility you can use bollinger
bands okay so we're gonna add bollinger
bands
and as you can see here the bollinger
bands were getting tight okay so this is
a good situation for a bracket to occur
and then here we have the breakout but
what is missing guys here what is
missing
bam bam bam
okay
you can answer in the chat if anyone is
seeing what is missing tell me in the
chat guys
otherwise i'll give you the answer
but
bam you can see what is missing
here is the volume guys and we didn't
have any volume increase during this
breakout so this is the reason why i
didn't pulse yes bro well done high
volume missing exactly this is the issue
so it doesn't mean a bracket that is
happening without volume can also give a
nice move up
afterwards right it happens but it's
just decreasing
the probability that it's working well
it's basically increasing the
probability of fake out so if you go to
breakouts that don't have this volume
increase
um you're basically taking more risk for
the same reward so it is not
something that you should
do very often if you really believe in a
stock and you really believe that it's
going to go higher so then sometimes you
can do it but
if you want to be a trader on the long
run you should not um you know think
like that you should you should just go
to the most perfect situations and here
the situation was not perfect and this
is the reason why i didn't post this
today we're still moving up by four
percent guys
not two percent today okay yesterday two
percent two day two percent so in this
situation what is interesting to uh
to do okay if you don't want to buy this
bracket because you are not sure this
bracket is good quality then you wait
okay and here we can wait a few days and
see what is happening and if we see
strong volumes happening on the way up
for now they're still weak but if we see
strong volumes happening on the way up
and then
here a nice consolidation
and a pullback then here you can try to
buy the dip okay so this is
um
this is another way of trading it is not
buying high it is buying low you have
basically two different strategies
whenever you trade whenever you trade
stocks you can buy high so buy right
away after the bracket or you can wait
for a bullish momentum to happen uh
on for example the weekly time frame and
then use the daily time frame to buy the
dip and this is a situation where we can
do that but for for the bullish
sentiment to be back we need to see
those strong volumes happening on the
way up if we don't see it and then we
see a pullback then same thing it's not
good to buy all right guys
i appreciate all the knowledge
yeah
i'm happy you appreciate that brother
i'm here for that as you know
i try to give you the
most information
okay so
this is the first setup we checked so
once again for this one guys nothing to
do today okay next one
okay we have mara
okay so mara i think i don't i didn't
have it yesterday and of course we have
a show move on bitcoin so we're gonna
analyze bitcoin guys very soon
uh maybe let's analyze bitcoin right now
because it is all related all right guys
so let's go to bitcoin
bam bam bam okay bitcoin is here and it
is ripping today we have some strong
moves happening
i'm not sure why did you see a news
about it no not really
okay i just think we've been in the
range for a while and then
trying to get out of it okay i mean it's
gonna go higher
okay
so here no big news on bitcoin we indeed
have a breakup guys okay it's a small
breakout it's not very clear but as you
can see
if we use the daily time frame
the 42 000 level it is a level yes that
i'm talking about for a very long time
it is a level that i always had on my
chart uh the reason behind is that it is
a very important level that where we had
a lot of reactions before either we get
rejected by this level or we find some
support when we arrive there as you guys
can see and once again the most recent
past is the most important so here in
gen 22 it was acting as support then we
come here resistance breakout
support
we go above then we go brutally through
this level we found some support at 27
and then again
uh two weeks ago and last week it was
the level where we were seeing bears you
know reject rejecting the price action
uh multiple times okay it's even a
little bit higher it's at forty two
thousand two hundred so now for the
first time in the past two three weeks
we are able to go above this level so
what does it mean
first same thing guys here we're gonna
have a look at the volume so on bitcoin
it's a bit more tricky because as you
know we have different exchanges so
sometimes you are not looking at the
exchange where you have the most volume
so i'm going to quickly have a look at
all of them okay
so right now i think i was on
by nance
and i was in bitstamp okay
so let me go on con base i'm just
checking if we have a volume increase
okay this is what i'm interested in okay
here look guys this is one i'm paying
attention to okay so this volume
compared to that and for now we have
decreasing volume
in kind of a range you know
consolidation
so it's a good situation for breakout
but we don't have a volume increase so
for now the move that we see today is
not a move that for me is good to buy
okay
then
i'm gonna do binance
okay so i went through all the big
exchanges
i can do kraken as well okay none of
them has a volume increase on today's
move and the move that we see was quite
big actually okay we we're talking about
a plus five percent move so usually when
bitcoin is moving by five percent uh
we have more volume training so this is
uh
i would say
nice move up but without volume so this
is not showing strengths from the bulls
this is showing that we are still in an
environment where anything could happen
all right guys
okay so let's do some more technical
analysis on bitcoin
bam bam bam
so we can here draw some lines once
again you never know
if the trend line you're drawing is good
or not until you have some consolidation
okay so for now
we don't know if the streamline is
followed by many traders or not so i'm
just joining it and then i'm gonna wait
to see if we have some consideration for
now we have a rejection here a first
rejection at 40 uh 43 300 okay
so this is in line with this trend line
so let's see if um
if we can see some consideration below
or not but once again to know whenever
the strong move
is going to happen you need to have some
clear signals for now we don't have it
so something like consideration breakout
with volume
uh re-test and then we go higher okay
let me just show you something guys i
think it's pretty interesting on bitcoin
um
look at that
this was in june 21 as you remember guys
we were trading around the same levels
around around 65 000 and we got
massively sold here
and then look at that it's pretty much
what is happening right now here we were
that's okay 68 000
there was a massive sell-off guys that
last for two months and then we were
moving sideways okay and here it was
exactly the same thing massive move down
roughly the same amplitude
uh
that lasts from april 21
till may 21 so we're talking 18th of may
okay one month here this one lasts from
november to jan okay so this one was a
little bit longer okay just move down
and then we moved sideways for may to
july so three months okay
okay it's weird
may
okay no sorry it's two months okay so
here one month down two months sideways
and here we did two months where we're
moving strongly down and now
22nd of jan
15th of march and now it's been two
months we are moving sideways so it
looks to me that this correction might
be over but once again look guys in the
past look at here we were a bit in the
same situation moving sideways on low
volume look here low volume and then bam
look at that volume increase okay that
happened here around 38 000
okay and this was the signal for bulls
that it is time to buy and look what
happened afterwards all right a strong
strong rally so i'm not saying the exact
same thing is going to happen i'm just
saying that if we see
this strong volume increase that is
happening after
a consolidation because here guys as you
can see
you can have a look at the bollinger
bands if you want to know if the
consideration is good enough
up sorry take take attack
look how tight they were okay look here
bollinger bands were
the tightest
sorry bam the tightest that we have seen
them in the past you know year right
here and this is when the breakout
occurred so remember that consolidation
on low volume is a good environment for
a breakout to happen because whenever
the volume is small you don't need to
buy
that many shares or hear
coins i mean bitcoins as you would need
to if the volume is high all right so
this is just a good environment for
reversal to happen whenever things are
quiet it's easier to make the market
move and here we are not in the
situation yet you can see bollinger
bands are wider all right
but they are getting tight so you guys
know what we need we need a
consolidation we need a consolidation
with the market stopping moving for a
week or two and then a strong volume all
right just like we had here it doesn't
mean to be
very big it just needs to be twice or
three times bigger than the usual volume
we had the week before right this is
enough so as you can see here the volume
we have right now is very small so
having twice
or three times that is not that
complicated all right guys
so this is the situation on bitcoin
we can very well get rejected for now i
think we're gonna consolidate i don't
think we're gonna continue moving higher
like that
um
the alternative scenario is that we are
still in the correction that is going to
last longer
so we need also to be prepared for that
and we can very well have a wxy
correction
with you know bitcoin bottoming at 28
000 or even 20 000. so just you know be
aware of the scenario that could also
happen it's going to go together with
the equity market so for now the equity
market is strong
as you can see so i would say that we
are kind of safe on bitcoin as long as
spy
is trading you know above this
445 level even above 430
uh bitcoin will not drop brutally unless
we have of course some news regarding
bitcoin
um but for now we are kind of safe but
once again this is not a reason to buy
bitcoin now because we don't have this
volume increase okay
can i ask you a question after yeah
basically on stocks
are you looking at a certain level to
basically buy protection
oh like right now oh you see this gift
of the question ah okay you mean on the
on the s on the spy sp on
are you looking at any point where you
would buy put okay because the fix going
down so the voice going down
and then if basically we have a retrace
because of some kind of okay so you mean
on the way up yeah okay okay so it's a
very good question uh
that's
basically
so let me try to answer that the
question is
is there any level on the way up
and any situation
where we think it is appropriate to buy
some protection
and
i think i have an answer for that so
once again i take spy chart or let's
take triple q guys because we know that
nasdaq is moving more than spy
uh whenever things are getting a bit
wide so it's better to get protection on
nasdaq if you want to get some
protection so here first very quickly we
are in the same situation the level is
is 350 that is the equivalent level of
445 for spy for both of etfs we are
today making a breakout above those
levels so let's see if we hold above
that and the question is what level
would you sell and in in which situation
so here the next resistance level on
triple q is pretty obvious to me uh
because we have the 200 day moving
average coming at 370 and 370 is also a
resistance level created by a trendline
where we had multiple reactions during
this uh breakout we had here support
once twice resistance one so i would say
that 370 is a good level to reload some
protection
now
if we arrive there with a very low
volatility
so we go we can keep a look at
going up slowly yeah exactly if we go up
very slowly
i mean
it's more risky to take protection
because it means that things are
calm and that
it's going gonna be harder for bears to
take back control so
what i would personally do is that i
would keep an eye on the vix and if we
are above 20 probably vixx would be
around here it's going to be i think you
know at the crossroad as usual
so things are going to go together so my
take is that we go back to 370 on uh
triple q that we go back to 460 on spy
and that at this time vixx would be
probably around 20 and we would need to
see if we have the same kind of
reactions as we had before where we
found some support here so if we're
above 20 i think it's a good trade to
make if we arrive
uh with the vix at 18 whenever we reach
those levels then i think it's uh less
likely to give a sending reaction okay
okay thank you
so we're gonna then of course guys uh on
my discord take some protection if we
want for now we still have some
protection as you guys know
i'm keeping this protection because
i think that uh things for now are not
um we are not out of trouble so by the
way let's quickly have a look guys at
today's
pnm
let me open my
application
and then we're going to have a look at
mara guys because mara is coming close
to some
resistance level
okay guys and give me some likes
i can see that you are here i hope you
enjoyed that
so hit that smash button smash that like
button guys
okay let me open that give me a sec
okay i'm coming back guys don't worry
okay just opening my application on my
phone
bam
so
yes i'm preparing for mara guys
okay but the analysis we've done on
bitcoin is uh gonna be very helpful to
analyze mara because of course
this is moving together
okay so
what was my level here
baba okay baba is very hot guys today
look at that
bam bam bam
okay give me a sec
measurement
i lost my screen i don't know where it
went
okay let me reopen okay so mara guys
okay so what was the level we were
paying attention to so the 32 level so
let's see if this level is still the
level that we want to
pay attention to
okay
okay
so why 32 level guys okay so this is
another technique that you can use
that i'm giving you here right now is
that whenever a trendline
like we had here we're connecting those
two highs it was broken here
as you can see on in october 21 and it
gave us a strong move up happening
afterwards but you can see that after
that it's it it has acted as support
here one reaction
and then resistance here so right now
it's gonna act as resistance again okay
so let me just try to adjust it
to have the maximum number of reactions
okay so i'm having this trend line and
look what other trend line do i have i
have this one
so here i'm doing the same thing as i'm
connecting the lows right so one
reaction two reactions here you can see
one two two reactions are four reactions
here definitely it acted as support then
here resistance so look guys what is
happening here we are coming back to the
intersect of those two trend lines and
this is a classic whenever you have two
trend lines that are uh you know visible
by other traders the market likes to go
to the intersect it's something that
have spotted guys that is uh
not very
i mean easy to understand but it's
something that we often see happening so
let's see my guess is that we go to 30
32.5
and here once again i'm gonna monitor
what is going to happen here we have the
200-day moving average at 35 so maybe
those two are gonna
act as resistance but basically for now
we don't have any buying signal you can
see the volume is still going lower on
the way up guys so this is not good this
is not bullish right so um so of course
it was bullish you know here so there
was a very nice trade to do but when i
say it is not bullish it means that this
move
is not very strong so it is unlikely to
me that it gets followed by more buyers
whenever we arrive at a strong
resistance and here like i said 32 is
the resistance 35 is the resistance so i
i think that bears are just waiting here
sitting here and this is the reason why
we had this low volume trading on the
way up if bears were lower then the
volume would be higher those are just
not trading because they don't think
it's a price that is worth selling so
they just you know retreated a little
bit higher and they're all waiting there
so we have here
a bear camp and if we are able to go
through this bear camp on increasing
volume of course we would be bullish so
the analysis we have on mara is um not
surprisingly very similar to the
analysis we have on bitcoin guys okay
so
that bam
okay
um
okay let's have a look guys at baba
right now because baba is moving nicely
today
so baba is the trade guys that we are in
for those who are with me on this code
you know that i gave you the perfect
trade guys
so let's have a look at that
this is a different technique guys once
again uh i remind you that whenever you
trade stocks you can either buy the low
or buy the breakout okay those are two
different strategies that work
completely differently
i like to use both i prefer to buy
breakouts but
if you buy breakouts in an environment
where there is a lot of volatility and a
lot of fear in the market like right now
you're gonna find yourself in a lot of
traps right so right now it is better to
buy the dip
and sell the rip okay we are in this
kind of market because of this
volatility so on baba this is exactly
the trade that we have done and those
who are with me on discord guys i hope
you jumped in this trade let me show you
guys this was here
bam
so for now i didn't post any alert for
the past two days but on march
11th guys i posted that by at 88 by at
75 all right we were at that time
training at uh 86
so the trade was buy at 88 buy at 75 no
stop loss as the company fundamentals
are very good compared to its price due
to u.s capital outflows all right so
this was the rational of my trade
and
then look at that guys today baba is
moving again strongly higher
so here we managed to buy the dip at 88
and 75 guys so it was the perfect trade
um and then i personally sell sold a
call all right so it's a covert cold
strategy because i think that this is
the right timing to you know whenever
you have shares to sell some calls
cashing some premium because we are in
an environment where uh the price action
is not likely to rip uh without making
some uh pose without some consolidation
so here i personally sold 130 call on
june maturity to cash in around 1 000 us
dollars premium against my shares
without taking any risk i'm just
sacrificing the performance above 130
130 because 130 was a strong support and
it is now a strong resistance guys okay
so even if we keep going higher i doubt
we managed to close above that level in
june okay so this is something that you
can
uh
remember as well guys
okay
okay
so
um
yeah so the 120 as you can see guys here
on baba
was a strong support in 2019
okay
it's right here 130
okay you can see here it was uh the
upper band of the gap up we had in may
17th yes technical analysis is working
on the long term as well here we had
some support uh some uh support
reactions around uh so at 130 around
deck in deck 18 guys
and
then it acted as resistance so now then
we dropped massively so now we are
coming back
uh the bullish momentum is strong the
volume traded are very big guys i think
it's the biggest volume that traded in
baba so we were involved in that volume
as well yes because this was a very nice
opportunity yeah it's not the biggest
volume that traded but close to to be so
of course whenever you have a strong
volume like that uh then the bullish
momentum is automatically related yes
because there are a lot of buyers that
got in there and you know they're just
talking about it everybody's talking
about baba so uh when everybody is
talking about the stock that is
undervalued then it creates some
bias to jump in the trade
so here once again 130 is the resistance
level that we are coming to and i think
that is going to act as resistance and
my scenario guys
is
on baba for those who are in this trade
so like like i said selling some covert
calls all right so one call against
hundred shares is something that is
smart to do right now because the
volatility is high whenever you sell
options you sell volatility so you get a
good price on the volatility and the
probability that we just keep going
higher guys in this market environment
is not that big okay so my scenario is
that we oscillate between 110 130 you
know and then i don't really know what's
going to happen but i think that's we're
going to able
maybe to restart a bullish cycle if
things go better between you know china
and the united states so it's going to
depend on how china is acting uh
regarding russia
and and how the united states are gonna
consider china regarding the the
sanctions so we're gonna keep an eye on
that of course
right
guys so
what else do you want to see okay so i
had a few questions are you in panama
permanently
i don't know let's see
for now i'm here for uh only two days
i'm gonna stay three weeks guys then i
need to travel to valley to hong kong to
dubai
but maybe i'm gonna be back here because
you know it's it's a very nice place to
be
so we're gonna see but for now i'm not
saying permanently
will you have live streaming if you go
back to hong kong yes maybe but the
thing in hong kong is that guys i'm not
on the um i don't have the good
uh hour i mean we have 12 hours
difference between hong kong and the
united states so when i'm in asia it's
more difficult for me to do some live
streaming this is the reason why i came
here as well
because i wanted to be here with you
when the market is open guys okay
so nd and m expecting to beat earnings
by 200 here comes the squeeze
okay and dnm so i'm gonna have a look at
that stock i've never looked at it
ndm sorry
okay
so actually as you can see i've done
already some ta here
but it was long time ago
so first we're going to do some trend
lines as usual so this trend is not good
anymore
okay guys so bam bam bam
all right pretty obvious guys so we have
here connecting the highs
we arrive close to a resistance
so this is for the trend lines then you
put some horizontal lines where you have
some reactions so here clearly i can see
that
the this was acting as resistance
because we had one two three four five
six seven eight reactions guys so this
is the resistance area okay
for now we are training on low volume
guys as you can see
okay the volume is decreasing so we are
moving higher but this move up is not
strong because it happens on low volume
so we don't have enough investors that
are involved to really know what they
think about the price action a lot of
investors have not uh you know taken
action for now so i think that the
resistance area is around 380 415 here
so we're gonna see ideally as usual guys
we would like to see a small
consolidation on
still low volume and then a breakout on
increasing volume alright this would be
a good signal
for things to actually go bullish here
let me check if we have some information
on the option market
but the technical analysis is saying
that for now it's uh
it's better to stay put and to wait
for more information
okay guys so bam
okay indeed we have something here
because the duty seat is at seven
uh
that
that the market cap is one billion okay
i would have liked to see a market cap a
little bit smaller than that
okay but what is
that 84 million
correct
okay now i don't have the number of
shares sorry this is not correct
let me get the number of shares here
okay 250 million shares
okay
just one thing on alibaba because yeah
basically uh you know see what's up yeah
yeah there is a news here if you're
interested okay well basically they say
that uh
alibaba uh had a decision to increase
its share buyback program
also that kind of helped your trade okay
and so did they buy back their shares
already or i mean as long as it declares
they do it you know it's going to have
an effect on the shares
i mean if you want to just read this
it's going to yeah yeah okay let's have
a look at that it's a very good point i
didn't check the news on baba so let's
have a look at what is happening guys
but uh just a quick reminder we already
had some news last week about the
chinese government
um
the that is
that told that they're gonna support the
market when they say that it means
they're directly gonna buy shares on the
on the market if uh they see some strong
moves down now if we have a look at baba
okay so this is
ramped up by back a sign of things to
come take watch
okay so 25 billion share buyback may
kickstart a wave of such returns by
catch cash reach chinese internet firms
okay
okay so you see it's like um everything
is going towards the same direction
because we have some strong support
happening on increasing volume we have
some good news about the company that is
going to buy back the shell so i'm not
exactly sure when they're going to do
that but of course it's a good news for
investors that you know want to uh to
buy so
everything is going towards the same
direction here
all right guys so what else i was doing
bam bam bam yeah so nndm i wanted to
check
the short interest which is actually
quite big guys okay
bam
so the total short is not impressive
okay
we don't have any synthetic shorts the
total shot is only nine percent but the
volume trading is very low so it's a dtc
at six and as you guys know the dtc day
to cover is the number of days that a
short would require
uh to
uh close their shock position if they
trade the average daily volume so if the
volume is low it is of course harder for
them to buy back the shorts so they can
uh pro you know they can just decide to
reduce the shot position if they see
that the dtc is too high okay so it's a
good uh indicator to keep an eye on as
well
all right let me have a look at the
other questions
how much do you make in an average month
that's a very good question so for now
uh what i'm doing guys as you know those
who are with me on this code i am
managing
uh
so i was managing two portfolios of
stocks one was twenty thousand us
dollars they are the one
uh with
000 us dollars because i'm trying to
have an investment that is uh doable for
you guys and for now
uh this year
i made i made around 35 of this
investment all right guys
so for those who are with me on this
code you are aware of that this is what
i'm sending to you every day
okay so now is better moving strongly
guess today is a good day so we're gonna
analyze all of that
but roughly you know five thousand okay
three four three four thousand us
dollars a month with this investment but
of course this is just something that
i'm doing for you guys okay
so
how do you get your signal so like i
said i'm using breakout strategies that
are based on volume volatility and
momentum okay you can use different
indicators to actually know whenever you
have a situation that is likely to give
you a good breakout and for those who
are interested to know more about that
just click on the link in the
description of this video and you're
gonna get you can get my course guys
where i explain everything and for now
all of those who got this course are
very very satisfied with it i received a
lot of good comments so thank you very
much guys because i spent so much time
working on that i really try to explain
things very clearly for beginners and
even for advanced traders i'm very sure
that even if you are trading for a long
time you see my course you're gonna
learn things and i'm giving a
step-by-step method of exactly what you
need to pay attention to what you need
to check what actions to take at which
time uh how to enter your positions how
to take profits uh when uh you should
stop last your position everything is in
the scores guys so if you're interested
uh just get your course join the discord
uh we also have a forum where we can
share different trade ideas and discuss
it together so guys come join us and
you're gonna love it you're gonna learn
a lot of things and this is the reason
why i quit my job guys because i want to
pass this knowledge guys everybody needs
to you know know some basic things if
you want to trade the stock market if
you don't want to get burned
right why is bbig lagging behind behind
one mark it is ripping okay a good
question
okay gme plus eleven percent pop up
okay so bbig
um i don't have an answer for that i
would say
so the question is why is bbig not
moving today and indeed
everything is going higher we have
nasdaq up one point three percent
jamie up eleven percent oil is
decreasing
uh
bitcoin is going higher
everything is bullish and indeed
he is just you know
lagging a little bit behind
uh
the only reason i could give guys is
that uh yesterday was a massive move up
okay
23
and after the strong moves up
that happened on some um
you know some news but that are not
directly related to the company
um
some traders like to just take profits
whatever the technicals are here the
technicals are good because we have
strong moves on increasing volume and we
managed to close above this uh trend
line
uh but they're probably still taking
some profits so i think we are in um
in a day when we have uh old buyers that
take profits and new buyers that get in
so the price action is actually not
moving we cannot say that we are
selling off here we are just posing and
it is actually good to pause so it is
important to look what is important to
look at in this situation
is the volume okay
so for now of course we don't have
enough information we can check under 15
minutes time frame information but i
want to see if we have a red day so if
we close around this level around three
it would be a red day because we closed
below the level we opened it we don't
want to see a high volume trading during
this day because we don't want a lot of
buyers to lose money all right if we
have a red day it means that sellers
made more money than buyers all right as
simple as that and we don't want buyers
to lose money on the way up we want them
to make money so that they you know
they're confident in their trade and
they sometimes even buy more right so
this is something that is important
for now we don't have the information
about the volume that is going to happen
today
but we can already check what happened
at the open
and as you can see the open is much
lower than yesterday okay
you can see the happen was here so
yesterday
uh we had
a lot of shares 350 000 shares uh
trading in the first uh 15 minutes and
here we have half of that so as you can
see we have just a small consideration
small correction happening on low volume
so for now this is not bearish to me it
is not bullish uh
either but
i don't see any big problem in here it's
rather looking like a buying opportunity
to me but like i said i would personally
not get into the bbig trade just because
we didn't have this consolidation before
breakout so no consideration means no
support no support means that you don't
really know where to place your stop
loss all right so this is the issue i
have here uh
for
4bbh
tomorrow bbi g moons i hope that brother
i really hope that
give us some place to make some money
but i'm giving you guys
i'm giving you that every day in discord
i'm doing my best to share with you the
the the best trade ideas i have of
course all the trade ideas are not
always successful but
you know we can have a look at the last
trade ideas i gave you so baba was a
winner
uh spy it was not really a trade idea i
just gave you some support and
resistance levels
uh cs i gave you cs guys capstone mining
corp so we can have a look at this one
it was a commodity trade
so i don't know if it's still time to
get in
but we had here nice breakouts
sorry this is crazy screws credit suisse
bam
okay so here i gave you this trade guys
for example same situation so for those
who want to get access to those daily
outlets just join us on discord but this
was
this was a case study guys all right
because we have a massive move up
as you can see
massive massive move up what we call a
pole all right this is a bull flag guess
all right here we have the pole here we
have the flag we want the flag to happen
on low volume as you can see here the
volume is decreasing uh small moves so
we need to have bollinger bands
tightening so this is exactly what we
see here
okay
and then
a strong move up above the breakout area
above the bollinger band with volume
increase yes so this was perfect we have
that and then we came back at 680 and
you can have a look guys this is exactly
the level i gave you on march 14th by
6.80 okay
so this was a winner
i mean i won't go through every trade
i'm giving you guys for now i gave you a
lot of energy trades that of course are
working well because uh oil is uh was
just going higher in the past week i
gave you all this energy trades when all
was turning around 95 because 95 was a
support
right now i don't have any alerts for
today
let me show you again my watch list we
have mara but we've seen that mara is
not the best for now
what else do we have ge i told you guys
we went through this one we don't have
the volume increase so it's not good
i have body
with we
level at 250 so we are still far from it
let's quickly have a look at this one
okay
okay so here as you can see we have
bollinger bands very tight we have some
concentration so this trend line is not
good anymore
so we need to find another trend line
that is you know
that is showing you that our traders are
using it
okay so it's this one all right guys so
here you can see i'm just connecting the
eyes one two three and here i have a
consideration with one two three four
reactions right so this level is 230 is
the level that is the resistance right
now we are trading on low volume
okay decreasing volume we can see that
the volume is slightly going higher guys
okay
so bulls are maybe trying something so
once again what we want to see is a
volume increase with a breakout above
230 so i'm going to change my level here
i'm going to put it back to 230 okay i
was monitoring 215.
okay and if tomorrow we have a breakout
here maybe i'm gonna post an alert i'm
gonna see that
food we are already in this trade
okay
we got in at 16.5
okay we have future that is coming this
is a new one
okay we have fissile guys as well that
is that is hot
bam bam bam
qs guys we have some opportunities today
so let let's have a look at that
so first uh qs we checked this one
yesterday
okay still not okay qs is not ready yet
to break out still trading on low volume
we are below this 17.5 level
so we are consolidating that's good
that's what we want to see we want to
see more consideration here guys around
this levels
so let me put 17.5 on the qs
sorry them
okay so qs is checked
we have futu fisel i wanna check those
two guys
it's very close on qs is very close i'm
going to keep an eye on this one and if
today we close above 17.5 i might post
an alert in discord all right
so bam what else
okay
so here's something as you can see up
this trend line
we have multiple reactions in the recent
past but the consideration is not nice
okay the bollinger bands are very wide
uh there was a high volume trading
during this
you know consideration that was not
really won so eliminated i don't even
want to have a look at more on this one
fiscella
if he said guys this is a stock where we
had a lot of interest
recently
okay and look guys i've done that uh i
think yesterday
i don't remember exactly here we're
considerating yes between 580
and uh seven okay
so this is looking good guys
we are in a good situation we don't have
any signal yet
we are just in a situation where a
signal could happen anytime okay why
because look at that
here you connect the eyes using the
logarithmic scale
and
you can see that the press action came
here it's it didn't come exactly on the
resistance level so here for example as
as you can see my reactions are not
perfect so either i move my trend line
because it's not perfectly
done but no or i switch scale i'm going
to go to the regular scale and i'm going
to check if the trend line is giving me
better reactions or not
not really okay
so i prefer to use the log scale
bam so here as you can see the 200 day
moving average is rejecting the press
action
maybe we can go on a weekly time frame
okay you see this is the little game
that you need to you know learn
how to do
try to really find the trend line that
is giving you the best reaction here i
don't have a perfect trend and let's be
honest uh so i'm not sure where is
exactly the breakout area
i'm gonna keep the daily time frame for
now so i would say that definitely 690
is a resistance level but we have
another one at seven
seven
thirty okay seven twenty seven thirty so
what i wanna see is a move above 730
with increasing volume same thing look
at the volume guys decreasing volume we
are coming close to resistance level
with the decreasing volume so this is a
nice situation that you want to keep an
eye on
okay guys
okay amc amc amc i've done amc already
you can have a look we're going to come
back to that of course amc is moving
nicely now
okay i didn't finish amc that's true so
let me finish fisell and then i do amc
guys
uh so yes official is right now at 690
guys so it's very hot all right so we're
gonna see if we have once again a strong
move up above 720 with increasing volume
uh i would probably post an alert about
the cell so i'm gonna put it in green
i like fishel
okay
future i don't like it
i guess i'm gonna just delete for two
guys so it's not gonna appear in my
alerts anymore
okay let's have a look at amc again
see if we have some more information but
like i said guys on amc we are moving
higher true but the volume is still weak
we are still below uh the rsi is still
below 50 guys so like i said at the
beginning of this live we want to see
amc um rsi holding above 50 you know
this would be a first sign that things
are different because we didn't see that
for the past three months guys so an rsi
above 50 for at least one week would be
very good news okay it would probably
help us to reach the 18 level maybe even
21. okay guys so here we have a lot of
resistances as usual when a stock you
know got
sold off like amc did
then it's harder to uh go higher because
you have a lot of small bear camps on
the way up okay you have a lot of back
holders guys that boat all the way down
here and uh that might might just exit
their trade uh whenever the price action
is reaching the levels they both all
right so that they close the position uh
without a loss so this is what uh we
could see here on amc unfortunately
um
but it's as usual guys there is a
process where the old buyers are getting
out of the
getting out of the tread and you have
new buyers coming in uh for now and what
you need to pay attention to is the
volume all right for now the volume is
low so there is this usual rollover that
is happening we are moving sideways like
i said but the very important
information about amc like i showed you
before is that the dtc has bottomed that
too and is now going higher all right so
we can see that bulls are taking back
control so the chart looks uh i would
say neutral when i look at the
technicals but it looks bullish when i
look at the option market
and we have a big event that is going to
happen around april may maybe maybe even
before all right but april may is
is what looks the more likely for now so
moving sideways when i say sideways we
can very well go to 21 but let's be
honest guys five points for amc is not a
lot even if today we're trading at 15
remember guys a few months ago we were
training at 40 50 60 so five points is
not a lot so we could very well go back
to 21 to 20 25 percent
uh but then back holders would probably
be at play and we probably gonna have
this kind of consideration you know so
this is my scenario guys this is the
scenario i'm having for the past three
months and for now this is what is
happening yes so we have a lot of ups
and downs it's not easy to day trade
uh we have some false signals like you
see here bullish signal that got sold
off bullish signal that got sold off so
the best thing guys is to wait uh by the
deep well once again we are in a buy the
low uh environment not buy high don't
buy breakouts by the deep and here
if we have this breakout that would be
happening on the weekly time frame on
the on the longer time frame guys this
um
this could be a very nice opportunity so
i'm gonna be here of course guys to uh
to show you uh what information we need
to look at but uh but we have time right
so just relax amc is looking good we
have time and we're going to see what's
going to happen later
okay
i have a small message from
uh from my guy here indeed nrp is a
trade that uh that gabriel actually gave
us guys
some time ago
and
let's have a look at that case so first
let me
give you back some
um
context about nrp guys so nrp is a trade
that we had in our portfolio as you can
see guys here
bam bam bam
okay
so here this was in september 20 guys we
got in nrp all right so this was the
first time i heard of the stock once
again gabriel who is here is a commodity
trader he gave us that trade in discord
uh we made some good money on it so this
stock is totally ripping right now so
let's have a look at everything that is
happening on the stocks it's an energy
stock
related to the
energy market of course
and look what we have here guys so
let's go to weekly timeframe because
this is a long-term move
first
we arrived in this trade here guys we
both the first time
uh around 20 23 okay because we had this
as you can see yes this is exactly the
usual patterns that
we are looking for this is what you need
to be looking for as well but once again
be careful not to buy breakouts in an
environment where where you have too
much volatility like right now so right
now um it is
you need to be extra careful i would say
but this breakout was a very good
quality breakout as you can see we have
nice consideration a strong move up on
increasing volume that happened on the
week of uh september 21
and then guys look at what is happening
all right this is the bigger picture
so here i prefer to use the logarithmic
scale
look at that guys alright so same this
trade was given to you guys in this code
uh you can see if we have a look at a
tenure chart
here i connect the highs
okay
let me
just them
okay guys so
bam bam bam nrp you can see here we
connect the highs
one two three
four five six seven eight eight
reactions and then look at that guys
this is a case study
because we had this build up happening
here on low volume and then here
breakout with volume increase okay as
you can see
breakout
here volume increase
after consolidation on low volume so
this is
really a bookcase study guess this is
the patterns that we are looking for
then we had a continuation move and as
usual when you have those inclined
breakouts that are happening
you then
usually go to the recent high
and get rejected so let's see what
happens here
it's the first time we go there so it's
a very interesting situation guys we are
actually
so bam bam bam maybe the streamline is
not perfect we are now breaking out guys
today
above 43 so let's try
to find the trendline that is fitting
the consideration the best okay once
again guys look at the tip i'm giving
you here whenever you have a
consolidation so here you can see we
have clearly a consolidation that was
happening for the past
10 weeks
okay
and then you need to find the trend line
that is fitting this consideration the
best so bam
here i would do something like this okay
so i'm here connecting this high here i
don't have anything
okay
and
then
here as you can see guys we have a
breakout
bam
on inc and let's see if we have an
increase in volume
bam
so yes we had an increase in volume guys
happening yesterday so if you look at it
on the weekly time frame
you don't see the uh
the volume increase yet just because the
week is not finished yes okay so but if
you look at the daily time frame
here you can see we are breaking out
above 40 all right clearly
with the volume increase
so this is a good signal on a daily time
frame but once again we're looking at a
pattern that lasts for a very long time
so it's better in this situation to have
a confirmation on the weekly time frame
so for now i'm personally
gonna stay put on this
but we can have some good information
some good opportunity happening here if
we are able to close the week above 40
with a weekly volume increase
okay
okay so g pro we can have a look at that
guys
cigar
any cash secured put trades uh what do
you mean exactly bro
cash secured put trades
i'm not sure to understand
what you mean but i guess you want to
buy some food options
okay let me have a look at t i g air
first because this is the first one i
have in your question
okay so i'm doing some trend lines guys
here and as you can see for now we are
far from this resistance area
okay we have this we so the first thing
i see is that we had low volume with the
consolidation so we can have a look at
the bollinger bands
okay so the bollinger bands were getting
tight
but they were not very tight and then
we had here this strong move up
that happened with a volume increase so
this is creating some bullish momentum
but
what i miss here is a clear breakout
okay so i don't have any trend line
we can use this one
okay here we have something
we have something but look the rsi is
still below 50. i mean bulls are
definitely trying to take back control
but for now on the medium term bears are
still back in control now what could
very well happen
is that we move
you know close to the 10 12 area so it's
a nice move up
and then maybe consolidate around here
this is
a possible scenario
uh i don't see any i mean easy play to
do on this stock so i would say that it
is rather bullish definitely because we
have a strong move up happening we have
some sort of a breakout um
we almost have an rsi on the weekly time
frame at 50. if i look at the daily time
frame of course we have some moves we
have an rsi that is even getting over
both guys
so the bullish uh so the sentiment is
clearly bullish
but i don't have a clear
i mean
you know
clear play to do the the only thing i
would do maybe in this situation is uh
if we retrace a little bit you know you
can use fibs to enter this trade so
let's see how we go
and then maybe you know
buy on the way down by the deep here
but because now it seems too late to to
get in this trade
buy on the way down
remixing
okay here you can see guys maybe around
five
five four fifty okay so those levels are
levels where we can see some bullish
reaction happening
uh
later
if i look at it on a daily timeframe
it's looking pretty good actually but
it's too late i mean if if you were if
you would have
shown me this stock
on
friday
i would have probably told you that it's
still time to get in because it was the
first time we are closing here if i look
at the bollinger bands here
i guess they were tight
ah they were not that tight okay you see
what i don't like is this deep here
because this deep is creating some uh
instability
some volatility
and the bollinger bands were widening
during the breakout so a good breakout
is happening after a
consideration on low volume so here we
are the consideration on low volume and
low volatility but here we have this
strong move down that is not great okay
if you have just one candle and it's
coming back right away this is
completely different but here we are
three we had three candles so basically
bears were taking back control on the
way down
and um
and then boost to back control but this
is just you know um we have a battle
that is too hard there is
now bulls are leading definitely
but uh the situation is not for me
very nice to take a position here i mean
the the trend can shift again it has
shifted
brutally a few days ago so i guess there
was some news of course we can have a
look at that
let me quickly check
so tiger
okay earnings
director resignation so this was on
march 21st i wanna know the news that
happened on march 18th
okay
significantly high friday after the
company reported strong top line results
all right so that's good news okay it's
it's some earnings that were better than
expected so let's check the earnings
on the 18th of march um
really
i don't see good earnings guys
i mean
the estimate was 4.17 dollars per share
and we got
0.005 so to me the earnings are not
good we had a negative surprise of 97
percent
so what was the news
okay give again a sec up
[Music]
bam bam bam why uptake fintech holding
shares are soaring today
fourth fourth quarter revenue okay it's
the revenue okay so we have big revenue
um
but
not good earnings all right but it's
still you know some positive news
investors reacted positively to that
right now we're going higher let's have
a look at the market cap
and
the short interest data
okay
so the market cap is one billion us
dollars guess so it's not small so not
easy to move
uh we don't have a lot of synthetic
short we don't have a lot of maximum
synthetic shots adaption market is quiet
we have some regular short that's uh
seven percent of regular short uh and
the dtc is four all right so i mean we
have some
some short uh in this market and
especially compared to the volume
but
for squeeze to happen it's gonna be
difficult guys let's be honest here
okay um
so like i said here if you if you have
shown me this trade on march 18th i
would have said that it's feasible but
the problem was that uh the ruling bands
were wide right now it's definitely too
late to get in if we see a pullback i
think that buying around
you know the fibs level so i don't know
how high this move would go right if it
goes higher you need to adjust your fibs
of course so let's say it just goes to i
don't know seven right
before pulling back then the levels to
buy would be around
485 you know something like this
so let's see guys let's see what we have
here hold on gme guys what a move up pop
up
moving up by
another it's yeah by 14
that's some serious move
so we are just you know destroying the
20-day moving average like i told you
guys i told you at the beginning of this
life that the 20-day moving average
would probably not hold
because the moves is very strong and i
told you that we could have a reaction
on the 50-day moving average right the
50-day moving average is at 109.5
we got a reaction at 109. so
let's see guys
let's see what's going to happen
but it's very exciting
it's a pain in the ass i cannot open my
interactive broker account
let me try to do it again stay with me
guys i'm just trying to do something
so
long
okay guys we're still here
just making a coffee
okay
if i can open my ink in try to broke
your account guys i can do some trades
with you you're gonna see what we can do
today i'm gonna keep updating you with
my watchers guys
give me a sec
okay
okay guys so here we are one sec stay
with me stay with me
[Music]
and then we're gonna have a look at what
gabrielle is doing today guys once again
yesterday he made 40 grounds guys in one
day today i can see the piano is red so
we're gonna find out uh so he's losing a
bit we're gonna find out
uh if he has some trades to do today or
not he already increased his position in
the gold silver spread
so we're going to have a look at that as
well guys
okay
he's out one sec guys sorry
for him
[Laughter]
okay guys so i had a stupid issue that
is now solved
okay
so making some money today so like you
see mostly coming from the baba trend
guys
so making some money on bada guys
making some money on gme
okay it's not incredible but it's still
a good day it's a positive day uso is
still moving higher as well losing some
money on my uh protection
okay i'm making some money on facebook
making some money on football
alright guys so
bam
what i want to do with you
either we do some day trading
um
let me first finish
my
watch list guys i want to go with you
through that
so what did we have here we had
so we did an rp
so nfp we said we need to keep an eye on
that and see at the end of the month so
let
note this guys so we're gonna keep it
keep an eye on this one so nrp
end of the week
okay
fisela we said that fissile is good is
doing great great so above 720 this
could be a good trade guys
okay then
what else do we have qs we went through
this one we said
17.5 so guys we're very close we have
some brackets yes happening so you see
this is another good indicator whenever
you keep a watch list like that and you
see that the global market is giving you
information that
you know we might have
a reversal because the correction might
be over and you see a lot of breakouts
happening on stocks
then
you know this is just one more
information to add that is telling you
that maybe this correction is behind us
but once again guys what i'm keeping an
eye on is the vix as long as we have
vixx above 20
we are not out of troubles all right yes
one thing i would add is if you have a
lot of breakouts yeah trade all of them
would be be very selective true i would
i would only try to keep like i mean on
my side yeah i'm trying to keep
like
like maximum number of trades at once
at least until they're not neutralized
so what basically they're at risk maybe
you have five six but not more than that
and once they are completely neutralized
then you can add more
very very good point so what is what
gabriel is saying basically so once
again he's
uh trading guys for more than 10 years
so he's um
the information he's giving us guys is
very precious and uh basically whenever
you manage a lot of stocks what you need
to do if you want to add more because at
some point i'm personally having right
now in my portfolio once again guys uh
this is the portfolio i'm managing for
you guys because i'm using a small size
bam bam bam i'm having right now 16 open
position so what
if you want to keep increasing uh do
keep making new trades fair enough
because you see breakouts are happening
so you want to increase your position
it's it's it's totally unless
understandable and it's totally fair but
keep in mind that you need to control
your risks you need at some point either
to take profits on some trades that
where you already made money or to move
the stop losses higher okay guys this is
uh the only way
thank you brother this is strong enough
okay guys one more coffee
okay yes so we're almost done let's
finish this watch list
okay and give me some likes guys only 62
likes that's not good enough
come on hit that like button guys
it's good for the channel
bam so what else do we have
this is done
okay thank you guys thank you thank you
okay
and the other two we had we had tallow
and nine but those um
those ones guys i already gave it to you
uh
yesterday and we are i mean talo is
maybe still good to do ah bbb why yes
sorry okay guys i i'm done with my watch
list i'm gonna do your um
your your stocks right now thank you
very much guys for the likes 73 now
let's go let's take this 200 likes guys
come on you can do it
okay so
our bam bam bam
tallow and nine i've already done those
two yesterday guys
um so i'm going to do the questions
you're asking me right now telugu
basically the level to buy is 15 for
tallow and 235 for nine okay so we have
time we're now above that levels this is
the levels i gave you guys one week ago
since then we moved higher
uh so if you see those levels again uh
you can get back to it okay so those are
the levels all right so now i'm gonna do
a little bit what you are asking me
you want to sell put options okay frank
you want to sell put options on stocks
or the global markets you're asking me
if there is any stock where you can sell
where there is a good trade to do by
selling put options right
i will get back to that
yeah gme is ripping that's great guys
okay
so okay so bbby was asked a long time
ago so i'm gonna do this one
first
exactly okay then i'm gonna answer uh to
you frank
but basically put options are good to
sell whenever the volatility is high so
it is still high and you need to be
above a breakout so basically it's the
right time to sell good options whenever
you just had a breakout and you have a
nice consideration that is creating some
support so i'm going to give you
examples but i have already a few in
bam
mind
so first bby guys long time ago this one
was asked
okay you guys can try to do the analysis
for me
okay because it's always the same thing
but tell me what you think
here okay so now let me just show you a
clean chart
this chart is not very clean let me go
on the weekly time frame
[Music]
okay
so we had a breakout here in gen 21
then we got rejected we found some
support and we're moving higher but yes
this is messy okay
this is not something clean up there is
no easy trade here as you can see
we had a very strong volume trading on
the red day
so we opened
here at so this was two or three weeks
ago remember that
and uh and we got brutally rejected on
the red day i think this was because uh
a lot of shares were bro were bought
i think by
i don't remember i don't remember
exactly the news let me have a look at
that it's important
but someone bought a lot of shares
someone famous
maybe it was the gamestop
ceo i don't remember
so it was on
martians
yeah yeah that's it it's ryan cohen so
uh gamestop ceo that
uh bought a massive amount of shares in
bbby okay so exactly exactly i got the
news i remember that guys i remember but
so we had a massive open
in the morning it opened very high but
look guys the bears won the battle so
how can we use this information for the
future whenever you have something like
this that is happening it's uh you know
a traumatizing event all right for both
because what happened here guys is that
a lot of bulls got trapped right
a lot of uh investors you know both on
the way down here right and look at the
high volume that was trading so what
does it mean it means that a lot of
buyers lost money all right
so uh because they bought this move on
this news and bez made money so right
now
uh those buyers they need to reorganize
all right so they need we usually after
this kind of event come back to the
first support level that was here at
17.7
it didn't even get touched and then we
started to move higher so this is rather
positive but on low volume look at the
volume trading here
look at the volume training here okay
so
100 million shares and since then guys
very small volume so what happened is
that here buzz made a lot of money okay
this whole move up and
they're probably waiting so this is the
major resistance line they're probably
waiting here again ready to reload i
mean if you make money if you buy you
can see the other way around if you buy
the dip on a stock you make money you
take profit higher and it comes back to
it are you gonna do the same trade
probably yes right so this is probably
what's gonna and we know that there are
a lot of them okay because all of these
guys made money all right hundred
million shares were exchanged so my take
is that for now bulls are slowly taking
ground because bears are not here bears
are waiting here guys all right
so
for now this price action is not giving
good information because it happens on
very low volume so we need to see what
happens around this level right so below
20.5 below 25
uh i wouldn't be bullish if i had
both which i will not do because i'm
buying breakouts after nice
consideration but let's imagine i was
stuck in the street i would personally
take profits uh exit even with a small
loss around 24 right just before we get
on this resistance because i don't have
any bullish signal here now if we
consolidate
and then we move higher with a breakout
with increasing volume then it would be
looking good because the level to watch
is 25 okay so i'll repeat close to 25
we're probably gonna have a rejection
from the bears then let's see what
happens if we consider it on low volume
just below and then we move higher with
the volume increase though this will be
looking good
so i hope answered your question bro on
bbby let me know
now let me answer frank sinatra
questions so he wants to sell boots okay
so frank sinatra like to take some risk
because selling puts is risky why is it
risky
because i mean depend depending on how
much premium you are selling all right
but basically let me show you the pnl
you have so let me first show you some
stocks where we have when we where we
had recently a breakout
the only thing like right now the wall
is low i mean if you look just at fix
so if you sell the vote there
true it's basically probably not the
best level
i mean
it's totally it's a very good point
um
so we can see in two different ways so
gabriel just told me the vol the
volatility is low okay because when you
look at the vix compared to relative
pasta exactly compared to the relative
past it's true that the volatility is
low
bam
so we can have different scenarios
either like i said we come back to 20
and then we move higher in this
situation if you sell the volatility
between 20 20 and 20
in this area it wouldn't be a good trade
because then it would be going higher
probably with the market going lower but
if you go to some stocks that have just
broken out from the recent resistance
usually when the breakout occurs the
volatility increases okay we are talking
here of course about the upside
volatility if you sell put you're going
to sell the downside relativity because
the volatility of lower strike
than the current spot
but it goes together okay
so i would say that it's definitely not
the right time to sell puts on the
global market all right because
definitely the level the levels are not
good but if you go to single stocks and
you find some stocks with a recent
breakout okay and try to find a good and
reliable breakout okay
then
usually the volatility is high so you
need to find a stock that moved strongly
in the recent past so we can check
at the alerts i posted recently
okay so nine
tallow okay
for example those two alerts
so we can go to it
so tallow for example so i'm just giving
you one example but here if you want
so now it's now now it's a bit too late
the breakout occurred too long ago so
the volatility has probably dropped so
it's not the best timing to do that
okay you know what bbig bro bbig is good
but the breakout is not good quality
okay but if you want to sell put bbig
volatility is right now very high
because of yesterday's move so selling
puts sure makes sense and i would go
i would not take a too big position uh
just a position
uh
that is equivalent to the number of
shares you would have bought for example
if you would have bought 100 shares just
sell one put don't take leverage here
it's very risky once again not financial
advice but i'm just telling you what i
would personally be doing
and here we have a good situation where
the volatility is probably very high
uh we just had a breakout but this
bracket is not very good quality so it's
not the best uh
the best trade idea i could give you but
here selling puts
that
are around add another 3 280 280 put on
the maturity april or may is something
that makes sense
okay guys i'm gonna come back with me
one sec
so
so
all right guys i'm back
so
frank sinatra
thank you very valuable how you explain
great bro i'm happy that i made it clear
okay
in what time period do you think talu
could go to 30
good question let's see
bum
okay guys we almost reached 100 likes
come on for those who didn't press this
like button yet please do it
okay so
all right so first
very good question because indeed 30
is the target
so here we need to have a look at the
weekly time frame
and it's not easy to answer this
question guys because
there is no rule
you know you can use some time cycles
okay to try to see when the target might
be reached
but
it's very hard to answer what i usually
do if i want to you know for example buy
some call options and i don't want which
i don't know which maturity i like to
take the chart and you know i'm used to
look at charts so i'm just trying to
find something that is visually
acceptable so here you can see that
things went pretty quickly we moved up
to 20 got rejected
so probably we would need at some point
you know to take some time so either
we're gonna take some time here and then
move higher oh you might take some time
here and then he'll go quicker okay so i
would say around
if we go to 30
i would say august you see just because
visually this is what makes sense to me
i just you know try to make some moves
that are
in line with what the market is usually
doing
okay guys
and so yeah around between let's say
between
june and december 22 okay something like
that around august september this is a
target that could make sense
okay what else do we have guys what else
do we have
okay you see
melon is yeah not moving much what is
jamie doing
jamie is the big mover today we're gonna
have a look at the uh oil
market as well i'm a bit surprised
okay we i have some questions okay
because oil
okay no it's good okay
[Music]
gme baby yeah
that's
the nice move we have today guys
let's have a look at it again
okay so as you saw we got rejected at
this 50 on this 50 day moving average
it's
totally normal guys there is no big uh
trouble about that what we want to see
now once again for a move up to develop
you know sustainably
uh
it's good to have elite some poses on
low volume okay so for now today it's
not a pause it's definitely a strong
move up but maybe tomorrow or the day
after you know just consolidating below
this 50-day moving average taking back
some energy letting some you know
investors take profits and new investors
to get in that would keep the position
longer is healthy for the market this is
you know the usual process that is
happening during a sustainable rally you
have some profit taking you have some
new buyers you know and you know this
whole process is making the price action
uh going higher sustainably so we want
to see that and we need the market to
breathe all right the market that is not
breathing
is not um a healthy market all right
guys
so here if i see a small pose on gme i
wouldn't be disappointed
okay
okay we can have a look at uh
the
the silver and gold so yesterday we took
a position on silver
so we should have been maybe a bit more
patient okay it's losing a little bit
it's using 50 dollars so it's a very
small amount because the position is not
very big yet so either we can increase
the position today so let me remind you
guys the situation we saw this trend
line okay we had here a breakout and
then we were pulling back we put we
pulled back we tested it so once the
retest happened
uh because it very often happens roughly
eighty percent of the breakouts that you
guys gonna see are gonna
be retested so after the retest
sometimes we just move strongly higher
but here we moved higher and then we got
rejected again
so in this situation we can maybe retest
it again so i personally bought
yesterday here okay on the way up i
could have waited a little bit but once
again
i didn't take a massive position so i
can either buy back now or i can wait a
little bit because as you can see we got
rejected here on the way up so maybe the
market needs a little bit more time so
uh so i would personally not rush i will
not buy again today
but if i see the price action because i
have call options so the time is playing
against me or the other way around if i
want to increase my position the time is
playing for me because the longer i wait
at the same level the more call options
i can buy for the same premium so here i
have 10 23 call options
and i'm gonna wait a little bit and if
in
one week maybe in two or three days if i
see the press action still at those
levels then i'm going to increase my
position okay
so this is the game
plan okay we can have a look at gold
so you can see guys we are indeed here
in a very different situation because
gold is very far from its breakout level
so
on silver i don't see any more downside
to come okay i will buy soon one or two
percent lower i'm getting in on gold i
wouldn't buy
uh unless i see a move of at least
three or four percent because this would
only be taking us close to the breakout
area okay
so this is the reason why gabriel
sitting here has an open position he's
long silver short gold and today he
decided to increase his position
by the way you want to tell us a bit so
there's something you see today
i mean
as you said yesterday actually i didn't
make 40 i'm like 35k okay so he made
only 35 000 us dollars yesterday
and right now on the position today i'm
losing about 12k
but i mean i'm not i'm not really
worried because most of it
is just coming from something that is
very unliquid
and i just think it's uh
it's coming on palladium spread so
palladium is already very liquid but
palladium spread is even more liquid
uh so i'm losing 70's there
but then overall i mean i'm already
worried the main trade i talked about
yesterday where my my trading crude oil
where i'm losing a bit today but nothing
to be worried okay and of course this
gold silver trade as well where today is
going against me so i'm losing how much
does it cost today just the silver gold
um trade because yesterday i reduced it
because i thought it was good level to
basically
take profit okay today i'm i'm losing
about
3k on it but
actually i was losing 5k before
but at some point i added my position
and since then it kind of reversed so
basically i made money on the trade i
made today
yeah okay so
at the at the worst i was losing 5k now
i'm losing i'm losing tricky on this
position
okay so can you quickly um
remind us what are your positions so
we have this silver gold spread so
basically he's long silver and on top of
that he he has a spread long silver
short gold so his overall
long precious metals with a spread
positive silver negative gold okay what
other positions do you hold at the
moment
like from the for the one that's gonna
be relevant for you no tell us all of
the i mean maybe not the spread position
but the direction
exactly so i'm short euros okay so his
shirt short euro dollar okay so we're
going to have a look at that and let him
maybe finish the other positions
which we discussed yesterday so long
credit short euro dollar
i'm looking at because
i mean in terms of
like just directional that's it that's
basically why now i have another one
which is on bitcoin i've always been
long bitcoin but i
i basically is so
i have covered called on bitcoin okay so
uh
well today because so what strike are
you selling so covered calls guys i
remind you you are long shares or long
cryptocurrency and you sell some calls
to cash in some premium and you
sacrifice the absolute the upside
performance above a given level so what
covert calls did you sell on bitcoin so
right now is not doing so well because i
sold the 42 000 okay so make sense it
was a resistance so i mean i'm
i'm losing on my calls but because it's
covered
um
i'm not losing yeah i'm not really
losing it's just that basically i could
have made more money if i didn't sell
the phone okay and how much premium do
you get from the covert calls you sold
uh if they expire out of the money so
when did you do this trade
i did it when and what maturity is it
when it was like uh
for when bitcoin was at 40 000. okay so
okay so around here so probably two
weeks ago two weeks ago yeah okay
so here basically he had a long crypto a
long bitcoin position he decided to sell
42 000 covered calls which maturity uh
like expiring this friday expiring this
friday so he took the bet that we won't
see bitcoin closing above 42 000 before
this friday so for now
he's slightly uh in the money on his
short call position
but
not a lot and how much premium do you
get from the show of course it was it
was a 900
a call okay so 900 for each call so it
means that if bitcoin closes below 42
900 you make money correct okay and how
many of those have you sold five five
okay so he sold five
uh covert calls so to cash in five
thousand us dollars in a matter of f of
a few weeks so you guys can see that
this can go very fast if you if you have
a position on anything that is big
enough
to go on the option market and sell some
calls if you are in a situation where
you think that we are not ready to you
know make some massive moves up and like
we saw before guys we did this analysis
on bitcoin we did it on mara
we are not in a for now situation where
we see big volume trading on moves up we
don't have any clear breakout we are
moving sideways so it's a very fair
assumption
to i mean it's a very fair try to sell
some covered calls on bitcoin if you
have some position to cash in some
premium and let's be honest guys you can
do it on gme this is what i'm i'm doing
as well but yesterday i brought it back
before in front of you and hopefully
but anyway the the strike was 160 guys
so i don't think we're going to go above
160 uh but you can do it on amc with
strikes around 25 you know 30 on jme 130
160 on baba 130 alright so roughly 10 20
higher
than current levels all right so that's
your cash in maybe not a lot of premium
but it's still uh gonna help you if we
move sideways and one more thing on this
bitcoin thing is at the beginning of
this week
so like this trade i told you was about
two weeks ago so on the beginning of
this week if you look at the bitcoin
option expiring this friday again but
for much higher strike like 48k
or 52k uh his option price was like
about 50
by by bitcoin so very very cheap
and and so i bought some even though
i don't think we're gonna go there i
bought some because it's so cheap
that i'm like if i'm being if my covert
call is basically being exploded
because i don't know you know like we
get we got we have a massive breakout
and everything is continuing
i'm thinking that at least
if we really explode
i'm gonna
buy this very cheap call
that's gonna make me uh some money on
the way up i i i basically
see this as you know casino money i
don't think it's gonna
do me anything but you know because i
pay like about fifty dollar uh by
bitcoin and i bought like what twenty if
i remember so so okay one k
uh
i just saw this as yeah just just casino
okay so you see he's selling some calls
on 42 strikes but he saw that the
volatility was so cheap on higher
strikes that he bought some higher
strike calls for a very very small
premium and the good thing about that is
that for some reason if we have a
massive move up on bitcoin that can
happen anytime
for some with some news or whatever then
at least the short calls he's saying are
probably gonna be refunded by the long
calls he both all right so this is
another way to sell some covered calls
uh
and keeping protection on the you know
some extreme uh bullish events okay guys
so keep that in mind
uh i know it's maybe not easy to you
know be aware of what is cheap what is
not you need to have some experience you
need to you know do this for some time
so that you know that for example the
one week 105
strike uh option on bitcoin is looking
cheap compared to what you have seen
before right so if you don't have this
experience guys join our discord because
we are using professional tools uh we
can we know what is the volatility of
everything i can retrieve the data and
check the volatility for you know a very
long period of time
this is what i was doing when i was when
i was working uh you know in banking i
was a volatility trader so we haven't
information about that but for retail
investors it's not easily accessible
let's be honest
and guys so 92 likes we're almost there
guys come on for those who didn't press
dislike button please do that
make me reach the 100 likes
okay
so
what else do i see after flexing today
okay we're gonna have a look at utter
and gn us 20 short
okay
melvin master hey
okay
so let's have a look
i had some other questions okay so i'm
gonna try to do everything guys so
melvin you're asking three so please
tell me which one you want to see you're
asking for bro
so i'm going to do the first one you ask
x e r s
okay
so first information we are trading on
very low volume and we are coming to
some resistance levels
okay guys
so we might be in a situation of
breakout so we need to find a trend line
that is acting as resistance okay so i'm
trying to find it it's first time i'm
analyzing the stock
i know that the breakout didn't occur
yet because we are still
um we are still training on low volume
so i can start from trend line like that
okay this trend line okay i get it can
you see how you find your trend lines
guys you first check for the
consideration
then you check if the breakout occurred
or not i know it didn't occur because it
didn't have any volume increase
then i start from here i connected this
high and i saw that i had another hike
here all right and this gave me a trend
line
so
right now we can monitor this so for now
we are moving sideways for the past six
months even nine months so i would say
that if we break out above 290
uh then it would start to be looking
good right below 290 we are still
neutral above 290 if we have a volume
increase it would be looking uh good and
the first resistance would be 315 so
scenario like that
okay is we can say that a little bit
more we break out we get we get rejected
at 3 15 and then we move higher this is
the bullish case i don't know if it's
going to happen but this is one scenario
that could happen
okay guys
okay let me have a look at utter
xers breaking out not yet brother i
don't see a breakout
okay
i don't see a breakout here if you had a
breakout you would have had
increasing volume i don't see any
increase in the volume so
so we don't have a breakout yet
okay outer
so we look at that
okay so i was using the regular scale i
prefer to be back on the log scale
okay
so as you can see
bam
i did some analysis about
here on march 9th and
i was making a scenario where we can see
that and we break out and as you can see
this is not what happened we moved lower
so right now we are in the exact same
situation so i'm going to give you the
exact same scenario it's of course not
the right time to get in we don't have
any volume increase
okay
volume are still low all right
uh we are considerating below the strain
line so this is good but we need a
breakout above those
resistance levels all right so we have
one at 305 and another one at 2.85
so utter is something that i like to
keep an eye on you guys because there is
a story with utter i was in this trade
uh i made some money i lost some money
okay overall i think i'm pretty flatish
i think i lost a little bit of money on
outer let's be honest
um
so i would be happy to make it back
but i need to find a good situation i
need to see those volume increase guys
look here for example the volume
increase we had on august 27th okay
so
i'm gonna put that in my watch list
okay
so bam bam bam let's see if i have it
already
bam
okay
so you see hatter is here
bam bam bam and i'm guys hatter is
already
under the radar we are already
monitoring it
but for now i don't have the alert all
right because we are still far from the
levels
i'm paying attention to
okay
270 i was looking at 320 so i'm gonna
adjust little bit my level i'm gonna put
it at three okay
because
this is where the breakout might occur
so let's see if this is giving me an
alert and you see now i have the alert
all right so right now utter is gonna be
in the watch list okay
thank you for the question i'm happy to
add this to refresh my levels
okay you want to be like matt course
i mean he's doing great so of course i
would like to be doing great as well but
i don't think he's a trader correct me
if i'm wrong
uh
so
i don't i don't know exactly what he's
doing but i want to get i want to teach
you guys how to become professional
traders this is the purpose of my
channel
uh of course i like to give you some
news some information but i'm here to
give you some tips guys about how to
take positions that's what that's why i
came here in panama guys sitting close
to gabriel
i can't i cannot reveal everything about
him guys but i can tell you he made a
lot of money recently guys so he's gonna
tell you more about that if he wants to
but um
but we are not you we we are not only
youtubers guys we are
both professional traders we have worked
in the financial industry for a long
time
uh so we have some knowledge and this is
when i created my channel guys i want to
spread this knowledge
and i want to you know just
bring you the best content that i can
and i hope you enjoy it
all right so what else do we have
okay i'm sorry i cannot see all the
questions guys
so
just join did i miss the million bits
yes so i did milan before and i was
saying that
uh if we
if we have a healthy consideration on
low volume today it's still looking okay
but the short interest is not amazing on
milan uh because they diluted uh the
shares we had the shared dilution on
march first
uh so the the short interest is not very
big
and i prefer bbig than milan personally
okay if i need to put but even bbig for
me the setup is not perfect but it's
looking better better than milan
okay
okay
i'm reading your comments yes you're
funny
okay
did double its recent daily volume
already today at 15
okay melvin very active member thank you
bro for sharing
this information
i was not keeping an eye on ensc so
let's have a look at that
okay yeah but bro
all right
fair enough it doubled the volume but
i mean
you
you need to compare it to the real high
volume days for now we
maybe we doubled but it's still
extremely low so all right it's we have
a good volume dynamics indeed the volume
is going higher
all right but it's still very small okay
so we still have very small volume so
it's good to keep an eye on here
especially because we have this low
volatility so i like to have this
it's a it's a good situation because we
have very tight bollinger bands look how
tight they are on the daily time frame
so whenever you're in this situation you
absolutely need to find a breakout
area okay
so here i'm using the logarithmic scale
okay we still have another side below 50
so you guys know that an rsi blue 50 is
still
not really bullish okay
uh i don't have any clear time frame
here any clear trend line sorry
okay we i can do some translate like
that but guys that totally useless
because
they got crushed without volume increase
so it means that nobody cares about it
so i'm not going to keep those kind of
trend lines so whenever you cannot find
any trend line
then you use horizontal lines so here as
you can see i'm a bit stuck
because i don't see any trend line that
can give me information about who is
leading bulls or bears
so i'm going to use horizontal lines
okay so i'm going to take a step back
i'm gonna try to see where are the
support and resistance areas okay i can
go in the very far past
okay nothing happened before it's a new
stock
okay so here
uh-huh okay i get it it's pretty obvious
okay
now that i see it so you see guys
it's very important to know how to do
how to do those trend lines because that
telling you you know
who is in control all right so we are in
a very interesting situation ensc i'm
gonna put it in my watch list thank you
for giving me that stock
why is it a very interesting situation
because
first you can see that we are trading on
very low volume
very low volatility as can be seen by
the tightening of the bollinger bands
alright so i remind you guys the reason
why we want to see the slow volume
training is because it is easier for
bulls to take back control on low volume
than on high volume because they don't
need to buy as many shells when the
volume is low to uh beat the best all
right so we are in a good situation now
we want to see a consolidation happening
close to resistance area here we have a
resistance area that is created by this
horizontal
line that was the support here that got
broken retested we meant we went higher
so we have one
two
three
four five six seven eight reactions
right and three in the very recent past
so this trend line is good and we have
this consideration with very uh
we with the bull intervents very tight
guys so
i like this uh situation i'm going to
add that right away in my watch list and
for now nothing to do but if we have a
breakout here with volume increase and
this is not a volume increase just to be
clear okay volume increase needs to be
okay look at what we had here
it needs to be at least higher than this
red volume okay so we need to have at
least
okay at least 1.1 million shares
training all right all right guys this
would be considered as a valid breakout
and it's better if we have two okay
so i'm adding that to my watch list
okay so it's a stop limit
it's a breakout
and the level is 130.
okay so i should have the alert showing
up
okay i'm refreshing the price so as you
can see i'm retrieving the price that is
now one 127 so of course the alert is
here okay so tomorrow guys we're gonna
have a look at this one it's interesting
indeed
okay
best year on youtube that i have seen
thank you so much bro this is what i
want to hear
okay
bam bam bam
dbig
okay
some of you only want to see amc i know
that guys but for now amc we have time
we're gonna see what's gonna happen
later
okay
so we can have a look at the other
stocks guys and especially by having a
look at the other stocks you guys can
learn how to
you know trade breakouts by the deep
and this is what is important
learned a lot from you brother thank you
bro this is really really uh great i'm
really happy to hear that guys
how about bb sorry i forgot bb you are
right let's get back to it
okay
okay
so it's been a while i didn't do some ta
on blackberry
pam pam pam
and upst okay i get this one i will do
it very soon
but upstairs i posted an alert on this
one guys we had already some nice things
happening recently so blackberry first
alright so blackberry i know guys there
is a lot of interest about this
okay
oh right so we as usual guys we always
start from trend lines all right you
need to find some trend lines where you
can see uh that you have some reactions
in the recent past so here the best
trend line i can do is this one then we
do horizontal lines
okay so horizontal lines guys
as you can see i'm doing it live with
you
we just need to find some recent support
and recent
rejections okay so here definitely we
had some support i have the 200-day
moving average coming here so of course
it's a very important level
uh bam bam bam is that the best one i
can do
and you can see even very long time ago
guys bam look
here how many times it was acting as
resistance support all right yes i found
the level
eight is the level to watch all right
guys eight is the level to watch so let
me adjust my trend lines so that we are
on eight
then okay
so for now bulls are trying to take back
control on low volume so as for all the
other stocks guys we don't have any
clear bullish signals
um so let's wait i'm gonna add
blackberry in my watchlist as well we
need to see us a consolidation and a
breakout above eight guys so i'm adding
it right now
okay so stop limit order break out
above
okay
then upst okay i can do this one i
posted an alert so let me check the
alert i posted on this one even before
checking the price right now
let's see if my alert was good or not
bam so i was saying
buy 121 buy 111 stop loss 96 target 185
so let's see
let's see if this trade was a winner or
not
okay bam so here we go
i think i would have got stopped here
let me check stop loss with 96 so you
know it happens
bam
when did i post that i posted i posted
this alert here so as you can see this
trade unfortunately wouldn't have worked
uh because we had this strong move down
that was coming here so let's analyze
again the situation
but
we had some nice move up here and then
best to back control
so right now we're moving sideways we
have those increase uh the situation is
different here so i'm on a weekly
timeframe let's go back on a daily
okay
this reminds me of amc when i look at
the child guys it's a little bit the
same thing move down break out
got rejected
move higher again
i would say the
resistance the domain the overhead
resistance is 195 right
um
i don't see any good trade to do here at
this uh levels okay if we get back to 90
you can try to make
to buy the dip but we have already
tested this level five times so it would
be risky i wouldn't personally be doing
it but with the surplus at 80 why not
okay it's a good risk we will trade
uh
i don't have much information here we're
moving sideways i'm neutral guys the
volume is quite big okay
the biggest volume happened on green
days so it's rather positive we are we
have a good uh move up but that didn't
happen on increasing volume but stable
volume
so there is no strong bullish momentum
here we are oscillating around the
moving averages
so
neutral here guys and i don't have any
scenario that i can give you uh
that could lead to a strong reversal
sign or anything so
not much more to say on upst i hope this
answer is good enough for you brother
i will keep having an eye on this one
okay so bb i did that already
okay you ain't selling bro i think no
one is selling that's good
hey bro here you go
dr jimmy always here thank you brother
bbig candy i
i did bbig already i did it at the
beginning of the video you can just go
back and have a look
okay it's just consolidating just above
the resistance so
it's pretty good
okay
but this trend line is not perfect guys
so we need to be a little bit careful
here
i don't see any any easy trade uh on bbi
g
okay
still making money here today guys
that's great
mostly on baba jimmy and amc
bam bam bam okay
so at all is down
cool bro
okay so pgd you want to check this one
sure
okay
we have a strong volume training
recently so this created some bullish
momentum but we're going to arrive at
some resistance levels soon on pdd
so
bam
i would say that
okay i'm gonna i'm trying to find where
where are the most um
the most visible
support and resistance levels
okay so here i have some resistance at
50
okay so
but given the strong volume we had i
don't think it's gonna hold all right
it's just a guess
but
from my experience whenever we had such
a big volume you know bears
are scared okay if we if you were
arriving here on the lower volume
uh they would probably have you know
tried to defend the 50 level but here i
put my i put myself in a bear's shoes
and i lost a lot of money during that
day okay because we had a strong volume
day with a massive move up of 56 percent
so i lost money at 42 i would probably
not be selling 50 especially that
okay maybe maybe we're gonna have one
first rejection but
my take is that we're gonna go above
that and here it's gonna be the real
question okay so rather around the sixth
level i would say
uh but maybe in one month so here i
would say that's
slightly bullish if we manage to close
above 15 it would be looking good to go
test the next resistance level around
16. but the big volume that happened
recently is giving an advantage to the
bulls on the short term
much love brother thank you
another chat
okay so you want to check
immx the chart looks brutal okay i don't
know exactly what it means but let's
have a look
okay
so indeed we had a massive move down but
once again guys
you can see that the interest in the
stock just vanished all right
so here
it was trading a lot at the beginning of
the year
now which is just correcting
i don't have much information here i
don't see any consolidation i don't see
any level that is a key level to take
back
i need to see more price action i don't
have a good visibility on what is
happening here
if we consolidate here this would give
us the information that this trendline
is the good one but for now i just did
it a bit randomly you know and
i don't have enough reactions to
uh be sure that this trend is the one
that traders are gonna use
so i don't wanna you know say something
that is not accurate so i prefer to pass
on this and wait a bit for more press
action but do not hesitate to come back
to me and i'm going to have a look at
this one again later
jamie ripping again yeah bro papa indeed
coming back to the
109 level the 50-day moving average
let's see if we're able to close above
that today it would be interesting
okay
bam so what is the smp doing guys having
a quick look at that
still looking good
okay we're looking good today
okay
i'm looking at it on the hourly time
frame so here for example you know i
could set up some trades i could start
to do some day trading guys
uh but i'm trying to find what is the
best because i don't want it to be
boring for you
but in the same time i don't want to be
doing too many trades
because overtraining is never good the
point is not to lose money of course but
just to show you how to day trade if you
are interested to see that
so here i'm paying attention to
i'm checking the 15 minutes time frame
maybe it's gonna be
a good one so i'm checking if the levels
are respected or not if the moving
averages are good to use
not really here
okay
the only trade i could set up we can
start guys
to do some day trading
so
you know we have here
a nice move up above the 445 level
okay
so we're going to use the hourly
timeframe which is good enough i'm going
to set up a trade with you right now
okay
and we're just gonna do some basic
things just use trend lines okay so this
trend line is good to use so we're gonna
adjust it
because we need on the hourly timeframe
to be very precise and we're gonna just
do some basic threads
uh where you're gonna we're gonna play
uh support and resistance levels to buy
and to sell so here let me address this
channel and as you can see guys the
daily timeframe trendline is not gonna
be the same as the fifth as the hourly
timeframe trendline so here
if i want to do some day trading first i
need to match very well the
consideration that happened recently
okay you can see guys here we have the
consolidation so
you see it's not the same putting the
trend at 446 and here so i think that
the strong land is better all right why
because
i match
one two three four five six candles when
i'm checking that
so 445.6
is the support level right now on this
py okay then here i'm not matching
perfectly back in feb 22 but i don't
care because i want to do some day
trading
so it's gonna be um so the recent past
in yesterday you know last week is much
more important now
i'm here set up
so
i'm not probably gonna do this trade
right now guys because
what's going to happen here might take
as very often guys it's a important
level let me take a step back i want to
explain what trend i'm going to do
but as you can see this level
is an important level why because the
445 level uh is
a level where we had a lot of support
reactions uh last month we have the
200-day moving average coming here
and everybody was a bit in the wait and
see mode what is the market going to do
now we have a breakout above this
200-day moving average uh
we had a little pose just before that
gives energy to the markets and clearly
we are bullish right
so
we are bullish but it's the first time
we go above this level and it's and we
didn't do that after a very long
consolidation so whenever you don't have
a very long consideration a re-test
almost always happens okay so here we're
going to buy this three tests okay so to
do that then you're going down audi time
frame
and here
like i said we need to be very precise
by using our trend lines because
uh everything is very important and
we're gonna
set up a trade
that is uh with a very tight stop loss
okay
so usually to set up the stop loss you
find some support uh level and you try
to be just below so here the first
support level i see is the 20 hour
moving average why because as you can
see it has been respected very well here
one two three
four times five six seven eight nine ten
so i know that traders are going to be
buying this level so first thing i want
to put my stop loss below this level now
i don't want to get caught in this kind
of stuff right so here i can put my
stop-loss
at least you know
242.3 241 at least 1.5 points below this
20-day moving average so around here
then the last thing i want to do is i'm
going to use the recent consolidation
that happened here and i'm going to be
just below all alright so i'm gonna take
the low of the scandal
okay so the low of this candle is
444.3 and i'm going to put my stop loss
here all right so i'm going to have
let's compute now what size i'm going
gonna use
okay
so let's do some simple math okay so
where do i buy first
so i'm gonna do this let this trade
right now with you guys i don't know if
i'm gonna get executed today probably
not because we are bullish right now but
i'm gonna be here to buy the dip guys
okay so i'm gonna show you how to buy
the dip
all right so the level like i said guys
whenever you have some trends like that
four four five point 5.65 this is the
level to buy and you always want to be
slightly above because you don't want to
miss the trade all right
so we're going to put uh buying order
just above this level so roughly here at
446
okay
so we buy at four four
four hundred forty six point zero five
always add some you know little things
above the levels if you want to buy
don't buy at a round number just buy
slightly above same for the stop loss
just use a stop loss just below around
the number because you have a lot of
buyers at this round numbers all right
so remember that and for the profit
taking same thing just below around
number not above okay so bind level here
stop loss
where do we put our stop loss guys so
we've have explained how i place my stop
loss
okay so i'm going to place my stop loss
like i said below the 20 hour moving
average because it's acting as support
uh in the move up
uh i want to be at least one point away
from it to avoid being trapped in those
small fake outs
and i want to be below this
consolidation so below the low that is
here so we said
444.3 and i'm gonna take a little bit
margin so 440
3.9 okay
443.9 okay so this is the risk that i'm
having
my risk is two dollars per share all
right
so i'm gonna take as it is a tight stop
loss i'm gonna i'm not gonna involve too
much risk in this trade
so i'm gonna limit
this to
uh let's say
500
okay 300 us dollars all right so max
loss
i want it to be 300 us dollars so how
many shares they need to buy 300 divided
by the risk per share okay so 147 40
shares so let's see what notional it is
because it's always good to um check
what is the national you're going to buy
so 135
number of shares so let's round it to
okay
round of that okay
times the buying level
okay
it's a lot
60 000 us dollars of national so you
guys can see just
i'm only risking 300 us dollars
and um
i have a very tight stop loss
and i'm going i'm gonna involve a
national of 60 000 us dollars so this is
what we call taking leverage so of
course here my risk is that
i buy
before the close and tomorrow i have a
gap up a gap down so i want to check i
don't want my risk to be too big so i'm
gonna just check some extreme events so
max loss in case of an extreme event
okay
so let me zoom in a little bit okay
and i'm gonna assume that tomorrow we
have a gap down of two percent okay i
don't think we can have something bigger
than that for now maybe three but okay
let's price it with two percent because
booze are taking back control
so
i i take my notion i'll multiply it by
two percent
and i have a maximum loss of one 1200
us dollars so maybe it's a little bit
too much
so maybe i'm going to take a risk per
trade
of 250 okay so now it's reducing
my number of shares to 116
and my maximum loss in an extreme event
to 1000 us dollars i think this is more
reasonable
so i'm gonna take this position right
now so the number of shares to buy is
hundred and sixteen
okay
we are all bricked on this blessed day
yeah bro
my guys from discord are here
okay bam so
let me take this position guys with you
i told you i'm here to do some day
trading some live trading so here we go
yesterday i took a trade on silver it
was not a winner for now but then it's
jan 23 maturity guys i'm going to add up
i'm going to add more on the way down
like i said and with time because i have
call options now i'm going to take a
trade on sp why
50 000 usd national
and we didn't discuss targets so let's
see i'm risking here
so
i mean
it's not financial advice guys i know
i'm giving you a very detailed trade but
i mean don't take this trade if you
don't have experience on the stock
market
if you don't know how to place a stop
loss guys if if you're interested to
really you know uh learned properly
things come to find me on discord guys
uh and you know we we need to go step by
step okay so i'm here taking a trade
that is already quite risky because like
i said the max loss if i get stopped is
250 us dollars but if there is an
extreme event i can use i can lose up to
1 000 us dollars all right and what is
the target guys
alright
so try to find the target try to tell me
in the chat
let me show you the chart
where do you see the target guys what is
the target
okay
it's not very difficult come on guys
give me that target
okay
so whenever you take a trade like that
you need to think about the risk reward
all right so risk reward when whenever
you do day trading should be always
above three okay you don't want to risk
what below three because uh if you have
half losers have winners and you have a
risky world of three you basically make
100
okay i have a good answer for the target
447 exactly so
let's check what risk reward is it and
first let's uh put this target exactly
where it should be okay so it should be
um once again you guys understand where
this target is coming from
uh and once again the most recent past
is the most important okay so here
as you can see we had one two three four
five six seven reactions on the hourly
time frame i put it slightly above
447.8 and here i'm matching this one
okay so this is the good level now like
i said whenever you want to take profits
you gonna take uh profits slightly below
all right so where exactly i mean
it's visual all right we're going to
take profits here so here is 440 457.
now like i told you we're never going to
put
a taking profit order at around number
we're going to go just below so 446.85
for example okay
so now let's
compute the
uh
potential gain of this trade
and then we're gonna check guys if this
trade is a win or not we're gonna check
if first we get in or not
so the
pam pam pam so to compute the potential
gain you take the number of shares
so where is my number of shares it's
here
okay sorry i did it a bit like
not very clean okay it's a number of
shares okay so we said this is the
number of shares
okay so we just divide the max loss by
the risk
okay
okay national is here
okay i don't need this one anymore
okay
all right so the potential again is the
number of shares so here
okay 116 so let's take round of this
okay so 116 shares
times
the uh maximum gain we can do on one
trade so target
minus entry level right
okay so we can make
1250 us dollars right
so it's a decent trade
so the risk reward is
in this situation
1250 divided which is the potential gain
divided by the maximum loss 250 dollars
so we have a risk rate of five so
it's good it shouldn't be higher than
five okay if you have risk rewards
higher than five
uh
i mean it means that the probability of
success is
i mean very low
uh in terms of probability it's around
20
now if you're a good trader you can
reach 30 40 percent
uh but it's still a bit low
uh so
not not higher than five a risk towards
should be between three and five when
you use this kind of strategies all
right so we have our trade setup now
let's pass it guys
okay
so
we go on sky
okay we buy
so we said i forgot
we buy at 446.05
okay how many shares 116
okay i'm gonna place it in gtc so if
if i'm not executed today i'm still
gonna be able to be executed tomorrow
okay
bam
bye spy okay i'm checking if everything
is correct okay my order is placed right
now i'm gonna place my uh
my stop loss so the same number of
shares
okay this is a stop limit order the
limit is going to be quite low because
we don't want to miss the execution so
the stop loss is 443.9
okay
so 443
0.9
now sorry this is the limit so we're
gonna go up to four four two all right
really much lower than the stop level
and the stop level is four four three
point nine okay we place that in gtc
order as well so i recap what is the
trade we're gonna buy at
so let me place that first okay
so now my orders are placed so as you
can see i'm having those orders so
buying order of 115 shares at a limit
price of 446.05
and i have a stop limit order at 443.9
uh
with
a limit price at 442. so this is correct
guys
it is good to go
so
i'm happy i passed this first trade i'm
hoping i hope i'm gonna be executed uh
okay let me have a look at your
questions gme is ripping yes bro papa
let's have a look at jimmy
indeed that's man what's happening 20
that's very serious
very nice move up i'm happy i closed my
short call position yesterday guys
so
let's check if there is any news do you
guys see some news
let me know if you see some news
i'm gonna check as well on my side
what's going on with game such as today
so let's see
[Music]
increase in retail investors interest
okay
that's not the news
lfg yeah bro
okay so it's just technicals okay there
is nothing nothing very very um
i mean there's no real news to me
here
bbh is still low
mc plus sex but you see guys so now
okay we are in a situation where you
know selling jimmy and buying amc makes
sense okay guys
so
i need to analyze that a little bit more
i'm not gonna do it right now
but like i said yesterday those two are
moving together and whenever we have
some strong moves up happening on gme
afterwards either gme corrects or amc
rips
so for now jme is ahead of amc
close to the 115 level
okay let's wait
yeah i mean
for now i'm just talking about
technicals guys so
when i say selling jimmy of course it's
not taking a short position it's taking
uh
you know
just reducing a little bit the position
in jimmy and increasing the position in
amc this is a trade that
i think would make sense but once again
guys i didn't analyze enough the data
for now what i'm seeing is that gm is
coming close to resistance level at 115
and amc
the same resistance level is at 18. in
the past whenever gme was turning 115
amc was at uh
18.
so um
so the spread is for now in favor of gme
and
usually we've seen the spread you know
keep staying stable so let's see if this
still happens for now i'm of course not
going to do anything jamie is way too
strong today so i'm happy to keep my
shares
increasing on amc is an option
let's check if we have something on amc
guys and i will be time frame
you see
because we can very well take a position
on amc just like we've done on the spy
okay but here the 20 hour moving average
is not respected as you can see so it
cannot be used the 50 hour moving
average is nice look at that guys here
reactions
reactions
reaction
one here and we miss this one okay so
this one is a good moving average to use
on amc
the 50 hours moving average is good to
use for now it's a bit far
so you might
never buy if you wait for pullback close
to this
moving average but if we see it
it's an easy trade to do with a tight
stop plus just like we've done on
spy so if i see this happening i will
take a trade as this moving average is
moving dominantly
dynamically um i cannot predict where
it's going to be later so i cannot set
up my trade right now but whenever i see
that
i will set up a trade on amc buy some
shares guys right
what else do we have
okay
guys so
x is not doing amazing today just
correcting a little bit i'm still happy
to keep my position here guys
what is bitcoin doing
sp why is still high i hope it's gonna
correct so that i get executed guys and
tomorrow we're gonna check if this trade
was a win or not and we're gonna take
more positions i'm gonna take at least
one trade a day with you guys and
depending on what you really want to see
we're going to adapt if you want to see
more day trading on amc gme
it's going to happen
if you prefer to see me doing something
else is going to happen to just let me
know guys i'm here to do what you want
to see
okay gme got rejected 115 i'm not very
surprised because it's the first time we
arrived
we arrived there so we're probably going
to have the same kind of
phenomenon we had at 109 you remember
guys 109 was a resistance because
on the daily time frame
the 50
day moving average was a resistance so
it gave us a level at 109.5
if you go on a hourly timeframe you can
see that the
109.5 level here
okay
it's also the 20 the 200 day moving
average on the hourly timeframe we got
rejected and it took us three hours to
go above this level so
we can expect
in the very best case the same thing to
happen so maybe a small
consideration here as you can see we
need to be very close to the resistance
level
to for bulls to keep control so here if
we see the same kind of things
okay
it would be looking good a consolidation
here uh
again you see this volume was lower than
the one trading before so it's important
to have a lower volume on the red candle
that happens on this uh consideration
and then if we have a breakout happening
here we would
we could even go to 130 guys this is the
next resistance level so let's see what
what is happening around 115
um
it's very exciting to watch that guys
okay you can see we have another
trend land that is coming here guys so
we have a double uh resistance that is
formed here so
i think we're gonna
struggle a little bit to go above it
right now we are just you know rejected
but
nothing too bad
it's even healthy guys
so let's see what's going to happen we
don't want to get rejected too far from
it we want to stay around this levels
okay and then move higher so let's see
guys what's going to happen um i'm
almost done for today guys give me some
likes i'm very happy that you are here
with me once again i'm gonna be doing
that guys every day
um
[Music]
i don't know you have something to add
gabrielle well just uh this thing we
talked about yesterday's uh jimmy imc
then when you look at yesterday i think
the period you look at this there was
three percent yeah so more or less maybe
closer to 20 yeah
yeah not saying there's something to do
but yeah i definitely definitely i
totally agree so this is what i've been
telling you guys and gabrielle is
reminding me what i would said yesterday
uh
but i want to you know
work on this strategy a little bit more
i don't want to rush but definitely we
can see that jimmy's trading with a
premium today
off around eight nine percent compared
to amc all right guys but i'm going to
come back to you regarding the strategy
because i need to analyze more more data
i've just done this uh premium analysis
uh a bit you know quickly i just
compared everything to the lows 87 14.5
but i need to do that on different pivot
points okay and then if i take the pivot
points where you have the most volume uh
this is going to give me a good good
answer about how this spread is um
trading right now compared to what it
was when we had big volumes trading once
again whenever the volume is big it
means that a lot of investors agreed
upon a price so this is what we call a
fair price we need to find what is the
fair price of mcn gym in the past for
example three months and compare the
level we see today to this fair prices
and see which one of those stocks is
trading with which premium and i will do
that guys and i will share with you this
analysis
and based on that we can take some uh
positions but it's not easy to take a
spread on stocks
unless you have positions on both of
those stocks which is the case so we
might find something to do guys
but i want to wait for that so once
again for today guys we are done thank
you very much for watching uh do not
hesitate yes to tell me what you want to
see once again i think that some
um
some day trading is
interesting for you to to to know guys
how traders actually you know work
during the day what we do all day long
guys because this is
you know uh how actually traders make
money guys day trading is a good
activity that is allowing you to you
know sleep uh correctly because you
don't have positions overnight and to
make some trades during the day lock in
some profit if possible so let me know
guys thank you again for watching and i
see you tomorrow cheers guys